Well.
Good experience by day.
Joe Rogan Podcast,
Ladies and gentlemen,
my friends,
honey,
Ben,
Susan,
what's up with some guys?
Man?
It's so weird.
Without the ads.
Yeah,
it's better that way.
We smash them in later and we were boring people.
You have to sit there and listen to five minutes to fucking,
yeah,
about the day you reward them that we don't have any.
No,
no,
no flashlights.
It's been awhile.
Show our first podcast with you.
You had Dick Pills,
I'm pretty sure and no band took one or you were talking about having a boner
for like six hours though.
Those totally unrelated.
He was getting some shit at gas stations to tell him that I got,
that was the beginning of a bad addiction.
I went deep.
We did what was,
it wasn't as many guns.
We ship involved for that.
No,
it's just Mexican viagara where they take like Viagra and mixed with the acorns
and call it a supplement and it's just isn't it?
You're not supposed to.
You don't know what you're eating.
Oh word.
What it is is like if you would by Aubrey explained it to us,
the hustle.
If you would buy like you know super rocket pills at the gas station and it says
guaranteed erection and all this jazz,
they're just selling you Viagra,
but they're doing it without a prescription.
So they're just putting Viagra in these pills and then saying,
oh,
this is our super secret supplement.
And when people find out at works,
they buy the shit out of it.
It's a way to buy viagara without a prescription.
It's not.
But the fines are very low and regulating them.
Definitely.
Good question.
Well,
the FDA regs,
they regulated if they find out that it's actually Viagara,
but a lot of times they don't find out there's a million different names and
apparently they get a small fine.
What RB said is some of the companies will change their name and then restart up
under a different name and did this the same fucking shit.
Then what are we doing music?
What should be getting boners
I mean they just did change the name.
Do you just take it and then
some of them times it doesn't work.
It's kind of like mushrooms where it really,
it's based on what you eat I find instead is it is never good though.
That seems like integrating motion is doing like their knuckle over to blow up.
You guys don't do that.
It doesn't work like that.
Mine does not know I'm getting sad.
Oh boy.
I wish I had those extra effects.
Go to the gas station convenience store.
We'll come back.
Apparently some of them at the gas station or just bullshit.
Yeah.
You know some of them are just like some scoopy herbs but how great that will do
Jack Shit that like maybe you just works anyway.
It could if you really think you got the super hard on pills,
the Super Chinese viagara well you just went global with it and I was about to
ask the question.
Isn't there a uh,
a Chinese supplement where they're using Rhinoceros Horn ground?
That's been a big fucking issue.
Yeah.
I was at the airport the other day and they had this big rhino photo that said I
am not medicine.
And it was talking about the use of a rhino horns and some eastern medicines.
Yeah.
There's some people that really believe if they believe it can bring good luck,
it can cure things,
it can cure cancer.
It's kind of amazing how you can set a trend,
you know what I mean?
Like obviously like that's a terrible,
terrible trend,
right?
It takes one person to be like,
I ground up this rock.
I found him in backyard.
It's
50 bucks.
The best ones,
just my childhood.
So Rhino seven,
it's the best one should
look at the explosion was running through fire.
How bad would your life soc if you saw a rhino running through fire,
like could you imagine if you like in a forest fire and you're trapped
and I'll write up
what
did you have cleats on the rhino is
is running through like this burst of fire.
That would be the worst thing.
You keep one of the worst things on earth or you could ever say
that's kind of imagine your life.
Honestly,
we've talked,
we've had bear talk earlier with Joe Bear Talk.
I got more questions,
man.
Okay.
What kind of questions?
Well,
uh,
so you were telling us that it's a a predator.
Yeah,
so it's in a different species of reaction and sense of it's perceiving
everything around it.
Bears are omnivores,
so they,
they'll eat.
Sometimes they'll ignore any like any game because they find like a big patch of
blueberries and Dell even ignore meat that's being left out.
They don't care.
They'll find a patch of blueberries on a hill and they'll just,
they'll just go to that.
I dare of smells.
Incredible.
So they are super sensitive though.
Like if you,
if you're over there,
they know you're there.
Oh yeah.
They know you're there for sh like unless you are really far away,
you could be like a hundred yards away or 200 yards away with the right wind.
They might not know you're there.
But if they're near you and there's no wind,
most likely they know you're there.
If the wind is blowing towards them,
they definitely know you're there.
They can just smell you.
And their sense of smell is way better than a dog.
And a dog's sense of smell is insanely better than a person's.
You know,
this is like the,
it's really hard for them to measure like what animals have the best sense of
smell.
It's very difficult to really kind of quantify it,
but what,
what,
what's even more difficult as us even imagining like how good a dog's sense of
smell is.
Cause it's a totally different perception at that point.
Right?
The smell like fear 48 totally.
Yeah.
And it's all,
it's like seeing an infrared or something like that.
The world just opens up into components.
Is there like a fear of pheromone that you emit,
I guess their mascot,
right?
It's weird
shit that you smell when you're around people that you don't like,
you know,
or that people that freak you out or people that might have bad intentions.
They have a weird smell,
you know?
Absolutely.
I have a nose like a,
yeah.
It's really weird to track bad guys.
I really can.
I swear to God so far this room is okay.
Oh sure.
Everybody's doing great.
Did you give gay Jamie a good sniff?
I didn't hear you smell great.
You passed the test?
Yeah,
I couldn't imagine like smelling everybody's farts.
Like in a city,
like if you're at a ball,
I'll give your a dog and you see a fart.
But if you're a dog you're eating shit.
So your industry you don't want,
I don't mind at all.
They don't have any cultural context,
you know,
yet.
I think
faith they will evolve and we will see it.
What do you mean like look a jumpy,
jumpy,
the dog.
I mean he is way ahead of schedule.
Do you think dogs have today?
Look back at the dogs.
I was like five from years ago and goes what?
A bunch of fucking idiots
freaking out when they heard the first siren.
Like they had their heroes.
You don't even know about.
Yeah,
I was like,
do you remember that one dog?
The dog to save the guy,
the first one to bear the bone?
Yeah.
My friend Steve or was telling me that they used to do show
knows where they would take like a raft filled with animals and they would push
them off of the um,
the,
the big waterfall a w what does it mean Jaeger?
No false.
Jesus.
They would tear,
people would pay to watch it.
It was still on the sidelines and they would push a raft of animals off Niagara
Falls to their death.
What?
Yeah.
It's like some early 1900 shit.
Why?
Because people,
you know,
it was a show like people get see the show.
I think they would pay to see,
so they would load this raft up with exotic animals that were freaking out and
trying to figure out how to get off the raft and then send them over the top six
sons of bitches.
Wow.
How weird.
Yeah.
Now does it sound an even entertaining,
depressed now?
Okay.
It's definitely not right.
Retaining,
it's definitely disgusting.
Definitely should be illegal.
Definitely should be punished.
But if you were there while that raft is headed towards the apex,
do you keep looking or do you go,
I don't want to
part of this,
that was like this too late
form of all the fucking Facebook shit of like distracted by it was like,
let's just watch something absolutely asinine or horrifying.
Yeah.
Because it's,
there's that shock factor,
right?
You know,
but I feel like that's not too far off from watching dog fighting even though
there's gambling and betting involved,
but like people that can handle that kind of thing.
I think there's just like,
I think there's some sort of,
I can't relate to this,
but I think that there's some sort of like innate,
um,
a primal instinct to want to see something terrible.
So it's like more terrible than what you can experience in your everyday life.
Maybe feel better about it or something.
Or your people are just sick and disgusting,
I think either warm.
Right.
It doesn't have to be one of the other,
I mean,
it could have been,
could be both or you should,
but that's for real.
Like people actually really do that.
Like,
that's not a joke.
No,
it was real.
It was all like a show.
Oh my God.
People would pay to see it.
Yeah.
We were just talking about this earlier actually.
What are you pulling in?
We're just trying to find pictures of it.
Oh,
we were just talking about this earlier about,
um,
being sensitive.
And I was telling Joe that,
um,
there's some,
yeah,
he goes,
we're talking about being sensitive that
I brought the,
I run the Feminine Energy Today.
God dammit.
She does.
And the way energy and the killer of the feminine energy.
It's true.
Um,
but I,
you know,
we were talking about TV and there's certain,
whenever I'm witnessing,
whether it's in a TV show or movie or real life,
some people really losing or people just being absolutely terrible to one
another,
especially when someone is trying their best and they just kicked,
kicked when they're down.
Yeah.
Guts me that I just,
Oh,
can cause you're a genuinely nice person.
She was my soul.
You're a genuinely nice person who would never do that.
So you see it and it drives you crazy.
One of the things that drives us crazy is the horrible things that we hope we
never seen ourselves.
You know,
like when we see something really pathetic,
there's,
there's horrible or mean or vicious.
There's part of us that like knows it's evil and knows it's bad and people are
being hurt and there that that part of us without a doubt is angry or upset at
the situation.
But there's also a part of us that hopes that were never like that.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
I think that's part of like what you see.
Even when you see like a murderer or we see like someone whose life has gotten
totally out of control and off the rails and into the woods,
you just go,
God,
could that have been me?
You know,
like that's one of the things that freaks you out the most.
Well,
it opens up the spectrum of what we're capable of.
You see some person who shows up at their job and just started shooting people
and you go,
what brought her to do that?
What brought,
it's usually not a her,
I don't know why I said hurts.
Is it ever been her woman?
Mass shooter?
That's a really good fucking question.
There was just maybe one or two.
I was just read.
There was this Escobar.
It's a very good question about how she's trying to be like even it's not even
at all.
Yeah.
There's an Esquire articles that get any ideas out there.
Ladies.
Let's just keep it cool.
Keep it,
cause everybody stay calm.
Um,
and it was really interesting because half of the article was just like,
uh,
a history of maybe just the last 10 years of mass shooting.
There's been a ridiculous amount of mass shootings are always mail.
It's in Time magazine,
except there's a big fucking stupid pulldown menu that we can't get out of the
way.
Where to go.
How about you use Squarespace?
You fucks.
Yeah.
Make yourself a really real cause that has happened or are we just going to
add from earlier
Rhino Horn?
We didn't eat.
Okay.
Squarespace isn't even on today's ads.
So stop talking.
Just stop.
On the other hand,
make an excellent website.
So I'm saying the other half have,
the Esquire article was about this dude who was foiled in his,
uh,
mass shooting attempt.
And he went to,
but they didn't,
it was like a frank abignail,
you know how he was this world traveling a counterfeiter and eventually they
caught him and he started working for the FBI.
I'm not aware of that.
Okay.
Is that,
catch me if you can movie oh,
DiCaprio.
That's about that guy.
That's about that dude.
And this was a similar situation where they found this mass shooter who didn't
actually get to carry out his plan and it started to use him to get into the
psyche of these dudes.
Oh.
And he talks about the process,
like,
you know,
it starts with isolation,
but the turning point was him starting to feel like he was,
he,
he realized he was better than everybody.
It was loneliness and alienation and then like,
wait,
but the reason is I'm the best and they're the worst,
you know?
And He created his plant.
So all these guys
tell us,
your serial killer is this your soul every three hours for a mass shooter.
In waiting.
Are you ready to pop,
Bro?
Come on.
Questions like that?
I can fucking find out.
Well,
mental illness is a terrifying thing because I don't know what's going on in
your brain.
I don't know what's going on in your brain.
I can only guess based on all the time we've hung out together,
that it's nothing scary.
You know what I mean?
I'm telling you.
Everybody smells good here.
I agree.
It's,
it's okay.
I don't smell any crazies are,
when in California postal shooting had history of bizarre behavior.
How many did she shoot?
A six.
Do you guys,
do you know that the woman,
um,
who there was a woman's secret service agent,
they've got overpowered by that guy that ran into the White House.
The woman there was a woman's secret service agent that was on the first line of
fire.
Like she was on the front line.
The guy got in and got ahold of her and overpowered her.
That's no good.
That's terrifying.
You're blowing it.
Got To master.
He got past her like that.
Was that recently?
Yeah.
Yeah,
a few days.
Okay.
I know what you're talking about.
It's scary as shit,
man.
This is scary shit.
Aye.
Well they just got outed for all this.
Yeah.
Stuff man.
Did you hear about all the shots fired on?
I can't remember what part of the West,
excuse me?
The White House?
No,
they're like seven shots fired into the White House.
The secret service didn't know about it for a couple of days.
What?
Yeah,
what was it like sniper fire or something?
someone just,
Oh God.
Yeah,
and that was the,
it didn't the woman,
the woman who ran the city,
she just resigned.
I mean it's the whole fucking thing.
And then there was a one woman who got shot who's outside in her car and she did
something in her car.
I remember he just shot her and drove her car onto the lawn.
Is that what it was?
We there,
we were in DC.
We were,
we were putting at the nine 30 club.
I've done that place.
Oh,
this is great.
It's fine.
That's a great spot.
Called that size in the country was awesome.
I got it.
We got to tell the story just because it's so fucking good.
So we,
we like,
um,
one of,
uh,
honey honey favorite live show activities is putting spirit animals on our
stage.
Preferably like birds of prey,
play guitar underneath your story.
What?
Ooh,
I like it.
I'm going to get appropriate.
So we used to have this mascot who was a,
it was a rooster
is fucking great.
And we,
if we took this rooster everywhere,
I got it.
It's on our Instagram page.
I can show you because it's really so much the rooster.
Yeah.
And it was like,
it was rooster Sofie.
It's pretty average.
Pretty accurate.
So how do I show this to you?
I'm not really good at this stuff.
Anyway,
we get to the,
we get to the venue and the rooster gets shattered by one of the employees by
accident.
And our,
our tour manager at the time,
Sam Sam really had an attachment to this rooster.
Like I'm upstairs,
we were downstairs and we just heard this
like three balconies.
But what's so great about nine 30 club is that they're a really incredible team.
Like the whole establishment,
like there's a real family vibe.
Um,
and the one of the employees incredible,
uh,
illustrative artists draws up a card,
um,
with his beautiful photo like drawing of a rooster with a big tear coming down
his face that says,
sorry about your cock.
And the whole venue signed it,
all of the employees in the venue sign it and we still have it.
And it was just one of the coolest things ever.
And you know,
it's,
that's actually a legendary venue.
Like the people there are just phenomenal.
The sound quality's is one of the best sounding rooms with evergreen spot.
Yeah.
I did that place years ago.
That's a great spot.
That's awesome.
I'm going to DC soon doing the Warner theater.
Ooh.
Damn.
On the 18th of this month,
she's torn all the time now.
What are you doing man?
I'm just telling jokes.
I just did my,
a comedy central special in Denver in November.
So what I'm doing right now is I'm writing new jokes,
shit,
load of new jokes.
How do you,
how do you approach that?
Um,
you right.
And then you take those ideas and you fuck with him onstage.
You really don't know what,
like last night I did a punch,
a new shit.
I didn't know where it was going,
you know,
and,
but I kind of had ideas where it would probably go and then there was some,
there's some things you,
you change when you're on the fly because you kind of realize like on the fly
that it'd be better if I said it like this or it'd be make more sense if I said
it like that.
Or I could also say this and you know you can under the pressure of like trying
to forge the idea on stage,
he come up with some fun lines,
bounce it off of anybody.
Like,
no,
you just go for it.
I don't want to do that.
What do you iPhone it?
You're just sitting in your car and you come up with shit.
Both.
I fall in it and I also,
a lot of times I found it into a print form.
I used to,
I used that thing that's note pad,
you know the nurse had you used the,
the little press a little microphone,
talk into it.
It's unbelievable.
If you ever tried it,
but did you have a droid the last time I saw?
Yeah,
I got rid of it.
So he's switched that shit up.
No,
but then I got a new one.
Yes.
Droid
phone pair to your phone.
But then I got it.
I got one of um,
galaxy
note fives or a galaxy.
Um,
a galaxy s fives.
I fucking love it.
It's great.
So can I ask,
you are writing questions?
I don't get really know how to check this out.
Watch why put it talking to this honey.
Honey ban is fucking bad ass sweet guy.
Watch this.
I love this positive reinforcement on the honey band is fucking dude.
She listens that amazing.
Listen,
I mean it just doesn't work like that.
It worked exactly.
I mean it's got all the words and you just talk into it and it prints it up.
And so I like doing that when I'm driving cause of,
I have an idea and like I could record it and maybe that's the way to go.
Sometimes
make us a sculpture.
It should be a sculpture.
I know what's going to be a dude with his pants off and the fucking Texas belt
buckle.
Did you know that the new Siri now does Shizam so you could just,
uh,
do the that,
what song is this?
She never said,
oh Sierra
does that even come up with it?
He puts it in the front.
There's a lot of loans in your pocket or a lot of room in the front.
My group,
no extra room.
Never
once he get off that rule.
There's some shrinkage I had,
but I don't know.
Sorry for being demanding.
This is your fucking place
demanding.
I like,
okay,
well see,
I don't know if this truly applies,
but I feel like a lot of people who write stuff,
song,
comedy,
whatever,
when you're young it comes or maybe not young,
there's a certain pain point,
like a,
an initial point where it comes very unconsciously,
you know,
just kind of flows out in a sense of like,
okay,
I'm just expressing myself.
And then later on down the road there's this conscious element that you have to
like retrain yourself to do something consciously that you may be used to do
subconsciously.
Am I presuming too much?
Well,
I think
but he might be the exact opposite.
Interesting.
Because in comedy in the beginning you suck so hard that you're terrified of
every stupid fucking word you're writing down.
You have very little confidence in anything that you're thinking,
but then as you get older you kind of understand what you think is funny about
something and you,
it also becomes like a different,
that's more of a conscious act though,
right?
Not necessarily that it's more of a conscious act.
It's just put the you,
you understand what you're trying to do now because when,
when you're young,
what you're trying to do is you're trying to kick ass,
like I'm going to get this joke and then it's going to be so awesome.
It's like I was trying to explain to a friend,
like if you made an album,
like if you guys decided to make an album,
like honey,
honey is going to make an album and our goal is to sell the most fucking records
of all time.
So that's what we're going to do with this album.
We're going to make the fucking album that sells more fucking records.
We're going to make $1 million or billion,
million dollars because I want to fucking yacht and I want a jet in a Bentley.
So if you approached writing your songs and that's all you were thinking about,
it would fuck you up hard.
Like you would somehow or another lose your shin.
That have to
happen to me when I was an actor.
What did you want?
Fucking money I want to do to survive.
And I worked for a little while and I had like a good two years.
And um,
it was like once I moved to La from,
I was living in New York and I moved to La and I stopped working.
And then every time I went to an audition,
I was just so desperate.
Like I couldn't focus on what was right in front of me.
I had to focus on what was,
what would happen if I got the job instead of I think people can smell that.
I'm not kidding.
Oh yeah.
It's totally,
definitely.
But also,
you know,
on a,
as a side note,
like that's why how I started playing music cause I sort of got,
you know,
thrown off course.
I was totally lost and I,
I moved to La,
I didn't have any friends when I got here.
I had like a boyfriend and we broke up and yeah,
Super Sad.
And then I wrote these terrible sad songs.
I know,
but it's true.
Like you know that that end result,
it's totally,
you're absolutely right.
As far as like,
you know,
creativity goes,
it's kind,
Kinda like not up to you too.
Yeah.
I think I like,
I really love being friends with guys like you guys because I don't know
anything about music.
So I get to appreciate it from this like really innocent point of view.
Like,
Ooh,
that sounds awesome.
Like I don't know anything about chords.
I don't know how you do shit with your voice.
I don't know anything about chords either.
And that's kind of what I'm talking about it no in a sense of like,
so we get to this point and this happens to a lot of people who go to
conservatories are like really study the shit does it?
They have this technical understanding all of a sudden and now they have to
spend the rest of their career figuring out how to forget about that stuff and
just like how do I come at this?
Like you're talking about like someone who doesn't really understand it coming
from an emotional place and you're actually using it for what it's supposed to
be used for.
Yeah.
I think maybe it's just like exercising too much focus on one area.
Like,
I think it's probably that like tactical proficiency is probably very important
in music,
but it's also like nurturing a creative viewpoint where if you're,
if you're doing something,
let's put it this way,
if you're doing something and you're studying,
this is not to knock studying music and practicing,
but if you're practicing,
say a very particular song and you're doing that song over and over and over
again,
like I'm sure you're gaining technical proficiency,
but should there be like an equal amount of time where you just explore making
your own sounds,
making your own,
using your own lyrics to having your own thoughts?
Or should you do like the classical music version of music,
which is consistently performing Bach,
Bach,
Beethoven,
like songs that have been done there in the can it,
you're just recreating them.
I think it's a little bit of everything.
Did you want to say something?
It is kind of a little bit of everything,
right?
You beat me to,
you got it.
The flow.
Okay.
Well,
it's,
yeah,
it is a little bit of everything because,
you know,
obviously like there's muscle memory when you're playing,
so if you're in shape,
it's just like working out,
you know,
I'll,
I'll do exercises of classical music just to like what he do.
I have
my chops up.
Um,
I have to do for us.
Not a,
no,
no.
I'll do some.
I mean me,
me,
my Lah la Lah.
Lah,
Lah.
Can You keep going?
Stretch.
Just move around a lot.
That's an impressive,
just been working on this new piece.
Just a warm up piece.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
it's cool.
It's like a,
it's got Keith Jarrett is very,
um,
almost led Zepplin light.
I could hear like Robert Plant.
I feel it.
I feel it baby inside of me from now I'm wearing big sunglasses,
wigs,
large hats.
I want attention.
We want to be able to see your teeth or your pants.
You could see my addiction whether you want to or not.
There are no pants big enough.
It's angry.
It's hard to,
it's on the move.
Constantly.
Constantly presents or boundaries of cloth to clean.
Dick
fucking honeybadger on.
My parents were mad.
Dick Rogan.
Rogan isn't even that big.
It's just crazy
thinking about it.
If you had like a fucking drunk kangaroo or a wild vicious rat,
I'd be more scared of the rat.
You know,
with Kangaroos,
like wobbling.
Didn't live explosive.
Well,
you could get the plague from a rat rat.
Scare the fuck out of me.
We've talked about on the podcast before,
I had a bad situation with a rat,
wants it,
a pool hall in New Jersey.
Me and my friend John went to this place to play pool and there's this fucking
huge rap.
I'll never forget,
just big giant fucking crazy yellow teeth and scare the shit out of me is like
getting bitten by the rat.
I have a great rat story.
This is a good one.
She's not as,
I like oil.
It's pretty dark.
So let me,
let me paint this with my tone.
Dark,
dark,
dark.
So I used to work in retail and the story.
Yeah,
let's call it.
That's actually really loud.
Okay,
I'll stop.
I'm sorry.
So I was working in retail and it was a horrible job.
It was like totally degrading as a human and all you would do is fold clothes
all day.
It was really expensive and these people would come in and spend ridiculous
amounts of money on clothes and they were just shitty and mean
and rude and rich,
whatever.
Not that that all constitutes,
but it,
it was just an unpleasant experience.
And from whether it was a customer or the staff that,
you know,
my employers were just not kind and they didn't give a shit about you.
So I was already,
I knew I was kind of walking on thin ice because I wasn't like enthusiastic
about being there.
It was just a job.
And um,
one day before the biggest sale of the year where people like late ladies freak
out,
I came into the store and that weekend there had been like,
there had been indications and evidence that there were rodents because,
and I,
and you know what?
I knew it were rats cause I could smell them.
I swear to God.
I was like,
I could smell.
Literally when someone says I can smell a rat,
there's a musty smell to them,
you can fucking smell them.
I never saw,
oh,
it's totally,
cause my first house in La,
I moved into off of a craigslist ad,
had rats and I knew I was like that smell light.
I know that smell.
That was from my old house.
That's a rat.
So long story short,
um,
the exterminators come in and set traps the night before.
So Saturday morning when like this big sale starts,
every,
all the girls were like,
oh my God,
you think they call it something?
I Dunno.
We walk into the store and there's like,
there's one dead rat upstairs,
there's one in the traps downstairs and the other one downstairs.
And then there was another,
there was a trap that had been deployed and there was a piece of a big large
piece of a tail and blood.
I'm talking blood all over the clothes,
all over the wall,
but no rat.
And one of the girls had walked into the front of the,
of the store.
And also you should know there was a line forming outside of people that wanted
to get in to get this end of the year sale.
One of the girls walks in,
she goes,
oh,
with that,
and it was the size of a cat and it was the rat that got that got out of the
trap that like lost its tail was in the middle of the store bleeding.
And it was like this big,
everybody's freaking out.
One of the girls was ballsy enough to throw trash can over it.
So it's like,
you know,
it's like screaming in this and so,
so at this point,
at this point,
it's time.
It is time to,
to open the store and all that.
People are knocking on the window and we were able to,
like,
we were able to sort of create a diversion and put some clothes,
racks so you couldn't see the trashcan people in while they were [inaudible] the
window.
Nobody was letting,
this was like a,
it was screaming like you couldn't no one [inaudible] so we call the
exterminator.
Oh,
it gets so much better.
The exterminator comes back.
We're like,
dude,
there's a fucking live rad in the store.
We can't open the doors.
We have a sale.
There's a line around the block,
like,
you know the owner,
everybody's on the phone,
everybody's freaking out,
exterminator shows up.
And he walks in and he's like,
oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a problem.
And he's like,
well I don't know my pellet gun.
So in the next thing I know he walks out to his truck and he comes back with a
two by four and he's like,
like you ladies might want to step back,
kicks the trashcan open and just fucking splat.
Like he was in the mid [inaudible] fucking blow up of watermelon in the middle
of the store.
So,
so then,
oh,
it gets so much better.
So after he kills the rat and it's like guts and end trails are all over the
place.
The Mat store managers like,
ladies,
we need to clean this up and open the store.
I was like,
are you fucking serious?
So like buckets of bleach and whatever clothing has the blood on it.
Just take it out,
we'll,
you know,
we'll cancel it out later.
So we're cleaning,
we're running around and I'm not kidding you.
The door's open five minutes.
And the manager who is my age calls me upstairs and she's like,
Suzanne,
can I have a word with you?
And I'm like,
yeah,
sure.
Whatever.
Go upstairs.
I get fucking fired.
She was like,
look,
you know,
we've been wanting to talk to you about,
your performance here.
And like,
I don't feel,
I know that you want to be a musician.
Just want to be.
And I was like,
fuck it.
Goddamn it.
But anyway,
I was like,
you couldn't fire me before he made me clean up the rats blood.
I had to clean up the blood.
Ben,
get fired.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Like it was one of those moments where I literally,
I lost my shit and then she was like,
well,
you can stay for the rest of the day if you want.
I was like,
you think I want to stay here and look at you.
I hate you.
You know,
horrible.
But it's such a good story.
So going through it was all worth it at the time.
Well it was just,
I'd never like,
I'd never experienced like any,
it's such a fantastical story.
Fantastical.
It's crazy.
Isn't it funny how story that is absolutely horrible at the time becomes
awesome.
Oh yeah,
it was,
it was a low point.
It was a low point though cause it was so insane.
Like when someone in in like dig like just degrades you like that.
Like she said,
I know you're trying to be a musician but like your heart's on in it.
And I was like,
of course I don't want to
cleaning up.
You're right.
I was explaining this to me this weekend about struggle and it's a very
important,
interesting point.
And he was talking about working,
struggling really hard,
doing something that sucks.
It's not fun at the time,
but it's fun later on for a long time.
Whereas something that comes really easy,
like fun,
like rollercoaster riding is fun at the time,
but after it's over has no fun attached to it anymore.
I was like,
whoa.
That is crazy.
Because if you think about it that way,
there's fun stored up.
Yeah.
But even if you have,
it's still 30 seconds.
It's woo,
we did it was crazy.
And then you kind of tell it,
but you just told the fucking harrowing story of a rat trapped under the
trashcan shrieking why a bunch of chicks are banging on the window and trying to
save some money and it's just fucking Rad and the guy comes in and smashed.
It is a great fucking story that at the time he must have been like,
fuck this job and you fucking fire me fucking of that day.
Like immediately afterwards,
look how great it is now.
It's like there's been,
there was like energy stored up in that moment that's come through in a big way.
We missing amazing crazy like acts of nature like that in any respect.
I'm sure you've seen crazy things out in the wilderness,
you know?
It's just like,
oh my God.
Well I've been talking about this the last few days I've been really happy.
Like about,
I'm always pretty happy,
but it's really fucking happy because I'm not in the fucking rain forest in
Prince Edwards Island in Alaska was sleeping in a wet tent and I'm like,
dude,
houses are awesome.
Plumbing,
electricity,
everything was wearing.
My sleeping bag was wet,
my clothes are wet.
I turned my light on.
I had a miner's light on when those little things you put on like a little
headband sits over the forehead,
like a third eye,
your enlightenment.
I turned this thing on in my,
in my tent and I just saw like it was raining do drops.
It's like literally everywhere you looked like the entire air,
all the air was filled with moisture.
There's nothing stays dry if possible.
We just hate like freeze dried foods.
You take walk.
We was drinking right out of the leg.
Five days,
we're drinking right out of the lake.
You just dip your,
there's no Giardia because there's no beavers up that high,
and not only that,
it's,
it's a lake that's made entirely rainwater.
It's not fed by a river or anything.
What did he say?
It rains so much.
It's just pure rainwater
tributaries,
nothing.
It's 160 inches of rain a year.
It's the rainiest spot in North America.
She just dip your cleaning.
Huge.
Oh my God.
I'll show you some pictures after the,
after the podcast sober.
This is amazing.
It's so humbling,
but beautiful.
Amazing.
You know,
solitary like really wild.
But when you get back home you feel great.
It's like,
I think that's the balance.
I don't think the balance is living by herself.
I don't think the balance is going off Ted Kaczynski.
I think the balance is going out to nature.
I'm going out on the limb,
but I think the balance is going out into nature and being around people.
It's like both.
Definitely.
It's like both like a nice
exchange.
That energy,
whether it's like physical contact or just you know,
attention perspective and be seeing the stars.
That's a huge,
huge,
you know,
we,
we just got to go to Hawaii fairly recently and you look up at the stars and you
see the Keck observatory.
No,
he did.
He got to go
your life.
It's in Hawaii.
It's on the big island.
Oh,
that's where we were.
Shit too.
Maybe we'll go back.
You got,
I'm scheduling my next trip.
I'm going to make sure if I go there that I go there when and when there's no
moon out because the last time I went it was fucking amazing.
But the moon was out so you don't see anything but the moon.
A few stars.
But the time before I went,
it was all stars.
It was Warren Moon and it's insane.
You can't believe,
you almost get angry that you can't see that every day.
Everybody should see it on a regular basis.
If you get to do it every night,
it should happen regular,
weekly,
monthly,
whatever.
Cause it just sets you back to the point of understanding what is actually going
on,
where you are.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I think we're,
we're blocked off.
We're in a car with like super tinted windows.
We look so cool.
You can't see,
we're obviously success dark out.
We can't see shit
obviously successful or being abducted.
It's one or the other.
You've maybe porn being filled one of the biggest one or the other.
But when we're flying around through the galaxy and we don't realize it,
we can get cocky,
but when you're standing,
you're standing on the Keck observatory and looking up and you see the very
defined Milky Way Galaxy.
It's so,
it's so crazy.
It's like you're,
you are literally on some sort of a spaceship flying with no roof and you're
flying through the galaxy and that's what it feels like.
It's,
it's everything is,
you just feel so small.
It's like,
wow,
this is fucking huge feeling of small though.
Yes.
Because it's not really that you feel small.
It's that you realize the enormity of it.
Yeah.
Everything,
the whole package.
It's like,
not even that you feel small.
It's just like,
it's humbling and I think that's one of the reasons why people are so God damn
cocky.
I think we fucked up.
I'm making like lights everywhere at night.
No,
I think it's what he said.
It's a balance.
It's like,
yeah,
people need to remember to get away,
you know,
and reflect and be out shut.
Shut it down.
Turn your fucking phone off.
Don't,
don't look at your Facebook page.
Right.
Go be outside,
just take it in.
I kind of felt like that when I,
I spent a summer surfing.
I'm not a good surfer,
but,
um,
I,
I used to live by the beach and I,
I diligently would go with a friend of mine who was teaching me how to surf.
And,
um,
I,
I had so many moments where like,
I was getting tossed around and you know,
where I,
I was scared.
And you just feel like this is,
this is the ocean,
this is,
this is huge.
This is so much bigger than,
than me.
You know,
and I,
I had so much respect for,
you know,
great mother nature.
It's a model I did,
but it did.
I really did.
Like,
I would have these moments where I would just,
I would get up at like six in the morning with my friend and go surfing and then
have this just awareness for the rest of my day and it's pretty fucking cool.
I would imagine that the people that,
that surf,
you know,
frequently that that's their hobby,
have it,
have a real essence about them.
This is definitely a spiritual connection.
Toad.
It was a little lime energy that's so much more powerful
than you when you were riding that wave.
It was just people that just go to the beach every day,
you know,
or I'll all the time like this.
One of the reasons my beach towns are so chill isn't something about the salt
like alkalizing or something good for you.
It's very cleansing.
I would imagine like if you go by like Santa Monica and you watched the waves,
like you'll,
he see the mist it,
you'd see the met like people are breathing that and the air's clean.
This shit we wouldn't hear.
This is a fucking hundred million cars and the air's clean there cause it's all
coming off the ocean.
It's just totally different sort of vibe.
It's a totally different life.
I mean what are we living by the beach guys?
So we have both of those live on the beach and the stars.
But the stars I think at that motherfucker of all motherfuckers,
it's like the,
the forest too though.
Forest.
Well everywhere.
I mean Hawaii is amazing too.
I was in Hilo,
went through Hilo and he drove like the mountain.
The Hilo is just one of the cities in Hawaii.
Are you thinking about Kona
on the Big Island?
We're talking about wife who,
we were just,
we were there.
There was this canyon,
is that what,
what the by the water?
Yeah.
There was this literally thousand foot waterfall running right off the north
west coast of the island.
I think that's the big island.
Yeah.
Wow.
It looks like drastic park.
Legitimately like didn't they film that?
They're probably,
I would imagine they did.
I think they did on a Wahoo.
They bought last.
Yeah,
they film bar.
Amazing.
We went in July with some really good friends of ours and um,
I,
I've personally never been anywhere tropical,
so that was my first time.
Hawaii was your first tropical trip like two months ago.
And it's the best,
what?
It such a crazy one too,
because it's not just tropical,
you know,
there's the rain forest every like the volcanic fields and the people are cool
as shit.
I love people.
You know,
people always say like you,
you'll,
you'll hear that like Hawaiians,
like negative towards white people,
you know,
a negative towards mainlanders.
But I just think there's too many of us that are Douche bags.
That's what it is.
We come over there and my fucking airplane ticket costs.
You get over here to your fucking stupid island man.
And these people are like,
my ancestors came over here in a fucking canoe.
Bitch,
it's tough people.
Fuck man.
What could we could,
we met this guy named [inaudible] Veka and he was helping,
we were staying in a place that was literally right on the beach so we could
walk out 20 yards and be snorkeling.
And he was just instructing us about the wildlife.
Don't touch that.
He
had learned in set in,
in a,
in a way that he would've just shrugged off.
You know,
he just brushed it off his shoulder.
This dude got an urgent or some sort of spine.
I wish I knew what spiky ones.
He got to one of those and they didn't put,
man,
this dude had it impaled through his wrist.
Whoa.
And you can't take it out.
It's too brittle.
He had it in his risk for a year.
It just happens.
It just slowly,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
that's both had you had one on your thumb and I had one on my foot and like I
felt it for like three months,
you know,
like it was,
I'd have these loans from like,
you know what,
for a jog or whatever and I'm like my fucking pinky toe.
It's all,
it's all swollen,
but it's a great reminder to,
it's just like,
that's like the stars.
I honestly think so.
When you have that kind of interaction with nature and it's still there and you
think,
fuck,
that hurts,
but it's because I did this.
It's because I was in that environment and I need to be exposed to that shit.
And it was just that one little spot where you can get right through it.
But you know,
it's okay.
Oh Jesus with a four year old stuff on it.
But the guys at the hotel,
they knew some shit and they had like some sort of vinegar and they put it on
it.
I put it on it for like 20 minutes and it was pretty good and I worked out that
night and then it felt better like I felt like if I worked out on it to kind of
smash it all up,
whatever's in there and it would slowly make its way out well and they make it
urgent is make it really clear.
They're not like surprise,
I got you.
They're
like
landmines
maybe don't do that and I was going to pick one up like a fucking idiot.
How would you do that?
Because I was fascinated.
I've never been anywhere.
Tropical
Rusty Blade and you look around and everybody knows anyone.
We picked that up.
My challenge
was amazing though.
The Sea Turtles Angels,
I swear to God,
they were just right there.
You just want to drink more of this whiskey.
I'm a big fan of all those animals.
We went swimming with dolphins,
which was amazing.
I had my four year old with me in the water.
I was holding onto her and she's snorkeling with me.
I want to expose her to as much really crazy shit early.
So it seems normal to her.
You know,
like I've already started teaching her martial arts
and the six year olds pretty good,
you know like and like probably take to that stuff really naturally.
I think it's,
I think there's certain aspects of certain movements that are just normal and
natural for people if you teach them how to do it.
But I think there's also like learned experience in DNA.
But anyway,
the point is like she wasn't scared of going in the ocean and being with the
dolphins,
cause she didn't know any better for,
you know,
if I waited until she was nine and I said it's,
she might go one on one if there's a shark,
but she's four.
I'm like,
it'll be fine.
She's like,
okay
women around.
I was on Qy,
I've been to Hawaii twice the time that we were talking about.
And this one other times I'm quiet and I saw a family and we were on a dock and
the dock was probably 10 feet off the water.
Right.
And there's a bunch of family members in the water and then a dude dangling a
little kid off the side and it gets like an Aflac and then they just drop it
sploosh Oh my God.
And then they save it and it's fine.
But that's the,
that's how they get used to it.
They just,
I don't know
either.
You're traumatized.
You're Michael Phelps.
That's how that works.
And then how Michael Phelps learned to swim.
I don't think what you asked me like I know that well cause you just referenced
him then,
you know.
But the point is that I have back up your claims are that create a model while I
was taking a little poetic license and
give that man is weed back,
giving him his weed back.
He tested him for weed all the time.
That's the problem.
We got plenty more with that.
Just to defend my Michael pelleve statement one more time.
We were talking earlier Charlotte,
my shitty stories create,
hold on.
Ben is slow with the cheers.
I'm really sorry for serving you guys.
Your drink so slow.
Turns it around.
I'm supposed to drive a bucket of whiskey.
We have a newer service.
We have a car service called blue bear.
No,
no.
We have a real car service on.
And do you hear about the Uber driver who hit the guy in the face with a hammer?
He hit the guy in the back seat.
The passenger with a hammer.
I have done in the front seat.
I don't know,
but the passenger like there's,
and I'm sure these stories are going to just keep coming out,
but first kind of Uber Freak out that I had heard of.
Okay,
this shit is unregulated in a seat was like really bad.
He could have been a dick.
Maybe.
It was like,
am I crazy?
You know what I'm talking about?
The guy was trying to bite his dick.
Uber Hammer attack may clarify firms responsibilities.
Wow.
Damn.
Well they've definitely been is that the guy got hit with the hammer.
Wow.
Oh my God.
You know,
for getting hit with a hammer,
he doesn't have to bash.
I felt they've been expanding at a pretty miraculous rate.
Like Uber and Lyft are just growing and grow.
More and more.
If you're getting higher volume of of employees coming in,
you're going to get crazy in there every now and again.
Right it good point.
Rational Suzanne,
proper rational.
What can we do about peace in the Middle East?
Suzanne net pass,
smart move.
You fucking person on earth you'd say,
oh I don't,
I don't feel equipped or comfortable to get into that conversation but I did
tell you,
I'm reading a lot of Chomsky lately and it's such an argumentative subject.
I'd rather just talk about rebuilding can wilderness good calls,
but also I feel like fucking Pansy at the same time.
I was thinking about this this morning,
like what do you stand for?
Like do you sit on the sidelines and let it,
like you have your relationship with it and you let it sort of transpire the way
it's going to or,
but there's already too many players on the field.
You know what I'm saying?
There's already over like 15 aside and they don't need more people being like,
ehh,
but without like two to Norfolk and Hornier Ben,
we have a platform that is continuing to grow.
And I'm not saying that that's our,
that's not what we're here for.
Like we're,
we're here to play music anywhere platform and spread love and you know,
be,
you know,
what we are.
But at the same time we also have,
uh,
an opportunity to,
if there's something really important that we believe in to talk about it.
Now I'm not saying I want to talk about peace in the Middle East because I,
again,
I don't feel qualified for that,
but I had this car,
like how this reckoning this morning,
or I was like,
what are you going to do Suzanne?
I'm like,
how are you going to handle this kind of energy if,
if that's the right thing to do.
You know what I'm saying?
Right,
right,
right.
I know I'm kind of babbling.
No,
no,
you're not.
It's that,
that anx of not really being able to fix some of the primary concerns of doing
our part.
I think you just said the perfect answer,
which is we don't know.
And,
and it,
it doesn't help the situation to just introduce energy into it to be like,
ah,
that's fucked up.
It's like,
yeah,
we all know it's fucked up.
I think there's people that are compelled to fix the system.
There's people that are compelled to point out the flaws in the system.
There's people that are compelled to inspire others.
Maybe that's where you guys are.
He might inspire others with your words or your music or your,
you know,
your combination of your talent and your points of view.
My influence,
people's ideas.
And then in turn that sets like,
I think whenever like someone like me who makes a lot of sense or someone who
speaks in a way that makes you realign your perceptions of the world,
when they communicate with folks and they put something in their head,
those people may spread those ideas out and add to them and,
and,
and it goes further and further and further.
And then eventually all of that influences the culture in a more positive way
than most protests or most,
I mean there's very few like really like angry violent reactions.
What they do is they cause people to become defensive.
They cause people to reexamine the situation.
But what causes people to really change themselves?
It's almost always inspiration.
It's almost always wanting to be inspired.
Like if you see someone that like,
have you ever gone to see like someone performed live and you just go fuck and
you just want to go home and play and you just want to go home and practice,
right?
Yeah.
Like that fuel.
Like sometimes you'll go see a movie and it just,
it's so good.
You just want to go to the gym.
You know?
Like sometimes these things happen,
you know,
talking about like sometimes you're in your car and fucking song comes on.
It just changes your state.
You know,
you just,
all of a sudden you just fee,
you get that feeling washes over you.
Fuck.
Yeah.
You know the,
those things for you and you,
Ben and Suzanne for you.
Can you do this?
Is your,
this is your avenue,
this is your avenue for change is what really set me.
Honestly,
I,
I've been like thinking about this a lot.
I really appreciate that.
You don't need to,
everybody doesn't need to try to fix the world.
Everybody can't fix the world.
Is this on the drive over here?
A little bit.
So anyone,
it's not about fixing the world,
it's just about making sure that I'm,
um,
I don't to say doing what I'm supposed to do,
but like not,
not,
not a sitting out when I should,
should be.
You shouldn't be.
You know,
I'm kind of like,
but I think the point of what he's saying is by following through on something,
you're passionate about it,
you are,
that that is the best thing you can do because it creates those environments for
other people.
Um,
and having opinions like expressing yourself once you've like,
like,
well,
you guys are doing,
you're establishing your music,
establishing your art,
and then you have opinions and then people go,
God,
this guy seems so cool and they make sense.
That doesn't make sense.
You know,
it's crazy.
I would
be becoming more and more comfortable with opinions changing in my own opinion
is changing because I think I,
I've actually been,
which I didn't understand it as this,
but it's a conservative mindset to be like,
no,
this is my opinion.
I'm sticking to it.
You know,
I've been reading this Dylan book,
um,
and the,
the is the reason I'm bringing it up,
it's fascinating because I'm reading this,
all these interviews with him throughout his career and I just got to 1980
right.
And He,
this is him like counterculture figure,
like [inaudible]
and 1980 he's a born again Christian,
like legitimately Christ,
the crisis of the way and the light.
This is what I believe in was a born again Christian hundred and 10% honestly.
And it's amazing to see this dude who so comfortable and just like inhabiting
what he is experiencing at that time.
You know,
let's look it up.
This is what I'm doing.
He wants to double check.
This shit is double checking from the post [inaudible] mouth.
Wow.
I'm saying,
but,
but it's,
it's a shocker to see these words cause I,
this is just my upbringing,
it when someone talks about Jesus that openly,
I get kind of freaked out because of my shit I guess.
But to hear him talk about this,
it just like realize we'd like people fucking chain.
This is a Bob Dylan,
jesus.com page
details.
Bob Dylan's Jesus years.
Yeah.
He was Bob Jones.
For Jews,
for Jesus.
So many different people.
Some artists,
you know,
it takes chances when you really see in this,
uh,
just in reading these things,
this dude was using a persona and still it's like Bob Dylan is something,
he sets it aside from himself and that's how we figure it out,
trying to create,
you know what I mean?
He's like,
that's Bob Dylan and he's,
I can kind of remove myself and do whatever the fuck I want.
Now I'm kind of,
uh,
not blameless,
but like a disassociated almost.
Wow.
I don't know about all that.
Oh,
[inaudible] documentary,
who's a film.
This is a film.
Well inside Bob Dylan's Jesus hears is a film,
which guy from the
towns it,
oh,
was he's the one that,
he was the one that got caught looking at child porn.
Got cleared.
He got cleared,
man.
Yeah,
that's right.
He got cleaned out and masturbation.
He got cleared.
But what does that mean?
That means like he was,
he,
this is a dude has been sexually molested as a child,
his life.
And he was doing,
um,
like a project trying to expose shit.
Right.
You know,
being like,
this is fucked up,
you know,
and you kind of got outed for and look,
I,
I mean,
I'm not an expert on it,
so I hope this doesn't bite.
Right.
I hope you're right.
I definitely don't want him to be a child molester.
Healthy viewpoint.
Yeah.
I try to look towards the positive at all.
It was,
but he's an odd guy like he does.
He admit while he made a statement about homosexuality or about being a woman
about how he had been a woman in his life and it was,
it was very strange because it was like there's
no in a sexual sense like he had been the receiving and of male sex,
you know,
so he had like played
catcher.
I think you'd have to talk.
Did Bernie just go
Pete Townsend here.
I'll read you the quote.
I'm so excited about my protein powder.
Joe.
I'm glad you're happy.
I really am.
I'm trying to bulk up Ben Jaffe.
What are you doing to,
to a bulk up?
Well first of all,
my back,
it's booked so I'm doing a lot of core shit is,
this is quote,
I know how it feels to be a woman.
I'm a woman.
Fine.
I'm just telling you,
just showing a we we unsuccessfully.
What's more important man?
Your back is temporarily hurt or time where
being gay.
Okay.
Sorry.
Did he talk to me?
That's under boys when he had his first period,
or I don't know if you call it a period when it's a man's,
but it's not like an egg got dropped.
He made me,
yeah,
you're not right.
You're not.
Do you accept a woman who's like,
like a transgender woman?
Do you accept that as a pure woman?
Absolutely.
What started me planning period,
and you're like,
listen bitch,
I know you ain't got no period for him to stop attending every month.
You're freaking out.
Maybe I'm having my period,
but you stop bitching about your fucking period.
Some transgender woman out there bitching about her appearance.
Transgender friends out there listening.
I'll fucking,
I'll bet you.
Well,
first of all,
let's,
let's backtrack.
So you had buck angel?
Yes.
Buck Angel,
your,
we talked about it.
We talked about,
I always wanted to have him on the show.
He's cool.
It's fascinating.
Awesome.
He's a really nice guy.
He's a really nice guy and it's,
you know,
I'm very flexible with my ideas about like gender.
I don't know.
I don't begrudge anybody their own sexual proclivities,
their own ideas about gender conformity and about gender identity.
I have been in this battle with a lot of transgender people over the last year
or so,
but it's purely because of one individual who is purely because of a woman who
used to be a man.
She was a man for 30 years and started MMA fighting against women.
And uh,
I was like,
yeah,
no,
set a bunch of rude,
mean,
mean shit that some things that we don't know that you know that I know.
You know what I mean?
Bunch of rude,
mean shit.
You know that if I like thought about the possibility that would make other
transgender people feel bad,
I probably wouldn't have said again.
But the reality is that it's ridic it's one thing to say that you're a woman,
but it's another thing to say that there's not some crazy mechanical advantages
to the male frame that you don't lose when you transitioned to being a woman.
It's not,
there's a one,
there's a 10% increase in reaction to like,
men have a quicker reaction time by 10% across the board.
But in some states it's,
I see.
That's the other thing.
Why do we even have a problem with a man like having a fight with a woman?
Like an actual man having a fight.
We want to,
if they both agree on it,
if the woman knows she's fighting a man and the man knows he's fighting a woman
and they both agree.
If you could fucking ride bulls.
Yeah.
Okay.
Watch he came.
Which you can.
Why can't you fight?
Why can't a woman decides she wants to beat the shit out of a man?
See if she could do it.
If they both weigh the same,
no reason why not.
Hey Joe.
Hey Man.
How's the record?
High Agenda?
How's it?
How's it record?
Record does,
did she win a lot?
Oh yes.
Every time.
It's not just a win win and like really quick,
violent way.
That's horrible.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well she lost once though.
She lost,
wants to some bad ass bitch.
She lost once.
Um,
but it was just like I,
you know,
all due respect,
not trying to be mean.
Her skill level is very rudimentary.
I watched her movements and there's nothing substantial about it.
There's like there's some MMA fighters.
It,
well no,
there's definitely technique involved.
She definitely knows a lot of techniques.
She's definitely trains hard.
There's no doubt about it cause she's fighting five minute rounds or a w I don't
know if they fight five minute rounds in a lot of these female organization.
Sometimes they lower the number of minutes,
but she's definitely talented.
She definitely can fight.
There's no doubt about it.
Um,
it's not like she's some horrible amateur that has no idea what she's doing
because she's knocking people out.
You know,
whether or not she's knocking,
you know what they would call sis gender.
That's what they like to call transgender people like to call people that were
born a certain gender called CIS gender.
What is,
I know it stands for,
no one knows.
No one knows it just,
it's popcorn.
Why do you call it popcorn?
You just do.
Okay.
Okay,
cool.
Lake Goulay Koolaid.
I Dunno,
I cause it's day
cool.
Give you diabetes.
Sorry.
Oh yeah.
See,
but for the first few fights,
she did admit that she used to be a man.
Ooh,
that's fire.
And she said that they did it.
It wasn't something that they required of her and she thought it was a mental or
medical.
Yes.
Okay.
Or I dunno.
I Dunno.
I shouldn't,
I shouldn't say,
I don't know exactly how it came out,
but the people that have fought or that didn't know that she used to be,
man,
we're pretty fucking upset.
Honestly.
This is so interesting.
Like this is fascinating that at this day and age,
this is an argument that we have is like,
you know,
you have to,
you have to label something and then it's like,
well is it this or is it that and it,
and it's both things.
You know,
it's like,
um,
if like,
is is buck angel a law like the butchest of lesbians or is Buck Angel a man?
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like first of all,
I respect buck and I think that he's great.
We met him,
he's great.
But like at the same time,
I'm kind of like just kind of fascinated by the,
the whole conversation to begin with.
Yeah,
sorry,
go ahead.
I was just going to say I,
I,
I think it doesn't to most rational people,
it doesn't really make it
different in a difference.
It's like self definition where you can call yourself whatever you want.
I think it's when people start proselytizing about it,
that's a problem because then,
I don't know,
it's invasive in this issue.
My only concern is that as a personal safety issue,
sure.
And there's a,
there's sort of like a,
I don't know,
I fuck,
I don't want to get involved in an argument,
but you know,
if anyone on the internet,
but it almost sort of feels like a unfair advantage.
Well,
no,
it's an unfair,
but it is,
it is an unfair advantage.
It doesn't mean that the woman isn't going to win or the other,
the other woman isn't going to win well and to do it.
But it does mean it's just that the,
the physical advances,
it's often like you can overcome physical advance with technique,
but you shouldn't have to.
Yeah.
There's certain amount of physical advance where,
I don't know,
I don't think the studies have really been done on like fighters.
I think there's been some studies on athletes and athletes reaction,
but I think the difference between being a man,
uh,
who transitions into being a woman in a competing in Olympic volleyball is very
different than being a man who used to be a woman.
You transitioned to combat sports because you're,
you're,
you're essentially dealing with having an advantage in dealing out concussions.
And that's,
that's a fucking,
that's a big deal.
This is a difference in the way we're shaped,
you know,
and the broader shoulders of the male,
the larger hands,
the,
the more narrow hips that different geometry of the body.
A man curve of the Brown.
Yeah.
So why do you run in here with
Laura Role?
Careful.
He's got an angry,
very fast and furious,
right?
Fucking transcend gender togs.
Yeah.
I had a question.
Have you ever
I thought a woman.
No,
no.
I sparred with them way,
way,
way back in the day
and in taekwondo.
Never in kickboxing but in taekwondo class sometimes you have to spar with them
but I never heard one.
Yeah I was playing basketball with linen.
Bet You do.
I really do.
Everybody gets sweaty.
People
will stay there right here and that's okay
while playing basketball and given that cause we wouldn't have gotten a seven.
What did that come on?
Everybody chills out and everyone just plays the,
I think it's kind of more on your volleyball team in the sense that people are
playing the game.
Then it's not about like I'm gonna fucking elbow this gun type physical.
It's like people are actually applying the techniques of basketball,
drama.
It's like when when dudes low in general like extracurricular and I'm not
talking about martial arts and like actual training that that you're involved
with.
My experience with extra curriculars,
sporting activities are kickball and basketball and saws are huge.
My world.
It's amazing because people get so into it and the ones that like get angry and
you're like,
we're here to have fun,
but at the same time,
that kind of sometimes also makes it more fun because then there's that guy that
everybody did you like,
wow,
look at fucking,
I dunno Ted.
When we were in Boston,
we used to have a comedian softwheel man.
Every Monday we get together and fucking yell at each other.
It was fucking safe.
Was screaming at each other over.
Honey.
Honey is very athletic.
We love all sports.
So if you guys want to get down,
you guys throwing the gauntlet heavy bat.
You know what I'm saying?
Fucking road road kill goes choir right now you'll be going back and forth.
So I'm on Twitter.
I'm going to show for us.
Oh,
they're the
best.
It can be the best.
I really liked.
Those guys don't have a lot.
They're awesome.
They're fucking bad ass.
They sent me one of their cds.
It seems cool.
This is a hotel kid.
Fuck,
are you?
Is that a suggestion?
Is throw to that
dark
[inaudible] we shouldn't be.
We shouldn't be
[inaudible] should,
first of all,
I did not mean to say that.
I think you did.
I [inaudible]
how much?
20% 20% sexy.
50% is confusing.
I'm 35 every few years.
Give a chicken drunk and sloppy kiss.
Yeah.
Nothing wrong with that.
No Man or not get granted.
Those,
those kind
gestures.
Go ahead.
Go ahead and ask anyway.
Have you ever kissed a man?
Never.
Do you want to Bruce?
I did allow myself to Condo just wondering about this Mick Jagger,
David Bowie Fan,
and I was thinking,
okay,
maybe am I like really wrapped up tight and connected to this idea,
not just of heterosexuality,
but of lifelong heterosexual practice exclusively.
Like if I so wrapped up in that that I couldn't like give a man a kiss and then
I was like,
you better shut the fuck up whole mall.
I said that to myself.
You're trying to plant these thoughts in my head.
You asked yourself,
yes.
I gave that up because I was trying to,
I was wondering,
I was like,
okay,
look at these guys.
Like I always,
I do little things where I will try to um,
experience things or go places or put my,
my mind or my consciousness in a,
in an unusual situation because I think that when you have unusual experiences,
whether it's even,
even if you like watch unusual DVDs or go to a strange place,
you take in new information,
that new information interacts with all the other information in your head and
you form maybe new creative ideas.
So I think like,
as a person who tries to be creative,
it's good to have as many experiences as possible.
Whoa.
Certain line that I go,
I just don't think I could do that.
And when I look at like Mick Jagger and David Bowie,
I'm like a wonder if they were like,
fuck it.
Fuck everything man.
Fuck Homophobia.
Fuck,
I'm a man.
You're a man.
Fuck.
I'm only attracted to women.
Quintessential rock star with a different spectrum than,
you know,
maybe not,
not too,
I don't know you're being,
but it's drug induced delirium and going through the,
you know,
I think those dudes at that time had,
had probably been through enough to say,
I've seen,
I've been to the limit.
You know,
I've,
I've seen the edge of the cliff debt,
but that's the old adage.
Like,
if you suck enough,
uh,
decks,
one day you're going to want to have sex with a woman.
Like if a gay guy gets to some breaking point,
hundred million,
Dickson is acid mouth.
He's like,
you enough blizzard of Dick Knopf please a woman.
Well,
it doesn't happen,
but,
but does it happen the other way where a man,
a straight man has so many different female partners at one day he knew
they fucked.
I want to be the guy that says,
I want to be the guy that says it a little spoon.
It says something.
If you're lying on someone's shoulder and they put their arm around like that,
what you do is you reach up with the left arm,
you protect the neck.
It's very important.
Is that something like this?
You want to do it like this?
You want to cop it and don't let go of that wrist.
Pin it down to your chest.
Dead.
You gotta you
got shrimp out.
I know you guys know about Hashtag Hashtag [inaudible] me about
the show.
Sometimes people will just be like Ben.
So funny.
What a
beautiful part of our history here,
Joe.
That's Lou Reed.
Wasn't that Lou Reed?
Was He cussing
David Bowie's God net or Steve Gutenberg?
David Boggs.
Goddamn free
town.
He's the man dude.
Ground control to major Tom.
That is the optimum for great songs.
Him Shit.
I'm talking about control major time.
What are adorable?
So cute.
Matching t shirts.
I didn't know.
I didn't get my penguin package
when your kids and people would have like fake alligator shirts,
they would take some of our stuff,
but you're not sure to big blue going out.
I want you to shit
[inaudible] relevant and important to this podcast.
You have a listener and made us a piece of artwork.
You say,
well look,
we've treated him with the utmost legal respect.
I'm not even kidding.
He,
he did.
He made to bill.
His name is Bill Patterson.
Um,
and he put $2 bills and put are there ones made shirts out of that dude,
that's like our emerge.
We live in the same town now.
Fine.
You guys aren't living until you don't have apartments.
Do you?
When are we going hunting all the time and you want to shoot now?
What do you want
honey?
Honey,
honey,
honey goes pig hunting.
Wild pig hunting.
We have the most likelihood of success.
Like if anything that we could do,
you know,
like a close rate.
But we have to take you guys,
have you shot rifles before
with two fingers in the same trigger brother.
I'm just kidding.
No,
but uh,
and I mistakenly thought it was,
you have the,
my friend Cameron Hanes drawing a bow on a nail,
but it really made me think the caption underneath it because it was talking
about the practice and the discipline that it took to be able to make that shot
and not hit the deer and the fucking paunch.
So it's crippled for the rest of his life.
But not dead.
And that gave me a new respect for housing honestly,
because I was like,
I don't want to go out there and and shoot something and
no,
it's not about trophy hunting.
It's about not being a good enough shot or not being skilled enough to be able
to kill the animal in a humane way.
Well,
it is possible if you go out hunting that you could miss
and cam has missed.
Cameron Hanes has missed.
Steven Rinella is my friend who's a master hunter.
He has missed and they have all wounded animals.
It is a part of the process.
If you deny that part of the process,
you're being dishonest.
Sure.
But you need to practice due diligence to make sure that you minimize that and
as much as is possible and can.
Haynes post was about my friend Cameron Hanes is a world famous bow hunter.
I mean there's very few bow,
hundreds of world famous,
but he's a maniac.
He runs ultra marathons.
Okay.
Regularly runs marathons.
He's run two marathons in a weekend.
He's running like a Friday marathon.
Is that the end of the world?
It could be here it goes.
What the fuck is that?
That's up to be a fighter jet.
Holy Shit.
Happy to be with you guys.
That's a really loud and the bunker.
Is that the Ebola plane?
What the fuck was that?
So we're uh,
we're sitting here.
That red man was doing something weird and it,
it almost sound,
it's so loud like a jet.
It sounded like a,
that was right at a fucking jet was going to crash and Canoga Park.
Hey if this is it right now,
like getting the love you guys too.
I mean that this is okay.
Talking about meteor impacts on the show lately.
Yeah.
Brian Callen and I got obsessed with me your impacts.
We were on Prince of Wales.
We started talking about all the various media impacts and super volcanoes that
have happened over the past x amount of years.
Brian's back.
Anytime you get any info with the Intel,
start checking the news sites.
What do you think?
Top Gun jets flying car radio.
Obama's in town.
It's mayhem.
They came to get me him
cause he was here yesterday.
I don't know.
Maybe he left today.
He said I'm one of those fucking jets.
I Dunno.
Find out I'm sad.
No.
Do you have enough snacks?
If we can get the fucking Taliban in the same room and give them some hash and
we all eat it together.
We could work this motherfucker out.
Musical part.
What's going to happen is we're going to read that.
It's going to be the end of the world and we only have like five minutes left
and then you two are gonna kiss and it's going to be June.
Me And Ben or me and Suzanne [inaudible] since this is it.
If this is our last time here on earth,
Brian will you please say world?
Oh Art.
Thank you Carl.
He says Derby r l l
were old.
Ps,
if it's the end,
you could say world once you know how to say.
Yeah,
that wasn't good.
That was weird.
It was so loud.
We're inside of a building,
you know like a pretty thick ass fucking regular ones.
I was going to be outside.
Everyone's outside.
That's why we should really job.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it what?
Anybody catch anything?
I guarantee it's just some people fucking showing off.
Oh my God.
Probably jerking off while they're flying really low.
Quit.
Quit this fucking job.
What's the best way he got to Jericho?
Jerk jerk off while you're flying.
Go a thousand miles an hour,
15 feet off the ground
pressure.
I could do it.
Well,
you didn't need all calm and it's like,
at least you can say you
do it then it's not.
Most people won't even question any further.
I was jerking off in a jet 15 feet off the ground,
going a thousand miles an hour.
Was Your Dick hard?
Why you asking me?
All you have to do is just start pulling on your Dick and technically speaking,
you were checking
out and really,
really going to town to be jerking off.
That's not true though,
because you know a penis that's a man can be three quarters hard,
half hard and still have the saddest orgasm of shame.
I know what you're talking about.
Fucking many orgasms too and it's like I was okay,
but it's not shame.
Shame is the feeling of guilt,
man.
Here's the difference.
If a girl calls up a friend that's a guy,
say of girl calls up a boyfriend and says,
oh,
I'll just masturbating.
I had like a half an orgasm,
the guy will go,
I'll come over and take care of that.
[inaudible]
it sounds like a vocal fry.
A girl has sex with him.
He goes,
I couldn't even totally get it up.
I just came home myself.
The girl be like the girl,
be like,
click
no.
I'd be like,
do you want to watch a movie?
Be like,
do you want to just spoon that breaking bad?
What?
That's so hot.
Say it again.
Yeah,
Ya.
You guys think we're okay.
We know the world.
We were just talking about noncoding
big beaten down by this fucking stupid system that's been in place since we were
babies.
We didn't ask for this stupid system.
We were born into it.
This goofy ass system,
but how do we want him ease?
How do we work our way out of it without being involved?
We'll get bench some world.
Hold on.
I have a yellow notepad and I'm going to take notes.
This is what I honestly think.
I don't think it's happening.
Whether we like it or not.
It just takes a lot of time and it's very confusing.
It's very confusing along the way.
And we're in the middle of it.
It's a hurricane.
We're in the middle of the storm and we've taken this crazy weather,
fucking cows and semis flying through the air.
We've taken as being normal.
The movie twister.
No,
I sort of did visually,
visually in my mind,
I was thinking about a film news footage.
One of the most impressive news videos I ever saw was this Dallas video we
played on the podcast of these semi trailers in a tornado that we're flying
through the air just spinning around in the air like the road,
like paper cups.
And they were semis like,
just,
just terrified that seen like the fucking
miraculous thing that the ocean,
yeah,
yeah.
Got You.
To donate your gives zero fucks.
So,
so I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Please allow,
write it down about the,
um,
the,
the subject matter that I'm writing it down.
So I think,
um,
the world is in a crazy place as we were discussing and yes.
Um,
you know,
there are people that are really,
really,
really fucking smart intellectually can analyze and overanalyze and,
and just inside out Ben's right there and like,
well,
and might just call it what it is and say it.
You know,
Ben?
No,
Ben,
you're fucking brilliant motherfucker and I love you.
I'm so glad you're my partner.
Okay.
All right.
We're having a good time.
But um,
but yeah,
you know,
he's got his issues.
Let's be honest.
Great,
great.
Bringing yourself down.
Just say Mako peanuts.
Micro micro
precision.
No,
it's not.
It's not a lot of precision involved when you're caught in a sleeve.
Okay.
What is it?
What part of this?
That's what I was tours.
Focus.
Joke has Ben's Jewish,
no vagina being physical sleep and sleep hood with that difference that envelops
the penis.
That's all I'm saying.
Hold on now.
I really do need to write this down to penis.
Goes inside.
Well,
you can go out
is really good at it.
I think in the crying.
He can't spit.
Not everyone's mouth.
Try It on everyone.
You got to know you're going to need to be proven.
It's like terrible joke.
You have to know when he can get away with it and you don't know why you'd know.
But you do know.
You know mom about this podcast when a girl sticks her tongue out and you just
spit on it and she swallows it.
This party is about to get fucking serious,
which she doesn't even flinch.
You just spit in her mouth and she just reaches her head up and tons.
You and Whoa,
I know I'm about to get some double penetration gave believe you spit in her
mouth and you can't even believe that.
She just swallowed it to let you know how gangster shit.
No,
there's a camera in that room.
no,
no.
You gotta go there.
I don't know why.
Why did,
why did you have to take the beauty out of it?
I would just want to capture it QUT and spitting in people's mouths.
Tate's bit in someone's mouth.
You there?
Remember that time.
Barris gets it almost once a week,
like really deep and sensitive teeth is a complete and total savage.
Oh Gee.
Savage original desk squad cru.
Tate is an animal and uh,
he was making out with this girl once and she goes spit in my mouth.
He just kills her hair back and fucking spits.
Right.
Are we talking in front of everybody?
I didn't look around happening again.
Do we run outside?
Jamie just ran out.
Jamie bringing a camera.
Yeah.
Brian ran to,
what the fuck is going on?
Is this to naval base?
I don't think this is that big of a deal where we are.
Here's the problem.
White privilege.
We're sitting here and fucking Canoga park thinking about what's going
privilege.
I,
me too.
Me Too.
Christine trainor jets going over.
That doesn't have anything to do with breath,
bro.
I'm kind of keeping in Russia and it's all gonna make sense.
What I'm saying is we look at war as something that happens in another place and
we support war.
If we do support war,
it has to come anywhere near us.
We never think that it has to come anywhere near us.
We just don't.
We think that it's happening in Iraq.
It's happened in Afghanistan.
It's been happening there for tow.
Well fucking years.
More than that.
Thousands of years with us now.
He's going to make sure it's okay.
Well,
he is one of the best investigative reporters and the Los Angeles area.
So prior to the world,
Brian Band is on the case.
He's out there smoking a cigarette.
He's going to come back inside.
It's going to go.
I was looking at it.
Of course he is.
He can't help himself.
He's a junkie.
Poor bastard.
You don't need to do this vape pen.
Don't work.
Do you want to go out there with them and smoke cigarettes
and I quit my vape pens
is that might be fucking RJ Reynolds propaganda,
whatever.
I feel fine.
I don't smoke them anymore.
No,
I definitely felt more like tension.
Let you,
cause I
taking taken the yoga,
the yoga.
I feel so at peace and I'm so happy.
I'm serious.
Yoga is so good.
So good.
Whenever I do what I go,
God damn,
I should do this more often.
What kind of Yoga you do?
I do a bunch of different times,
but fucking shit about beat crumbs.
Well,
it's like calling it hot yoga because apparently I'm not,
I don't even feel bad saying this beak room.
The Guy who developed this,
uh,
this brand,
which is a series of poses and he kind of took for himself as his zone is a
Douche.
Like,
I don't know.
He's just going to give you enlightenment through the head of his penis.
Okay.
Everybody has a different method.
Some have Koana like what is the sound of one hand clapping?
Any more offensive than him trying to fuck you.
Yes.
Go ahead and answer that competently.
He just said yes.
You said it's more offensive.
More the sound of one hand clapping is more offensive.
Fuck,
sorry,
I blew it on like a rape apologist.
You asshole.
Everyone's got their opinion.
Rape apologists
whole.
I'm part South American.
Oh,
okay.
Well at least
I'm thinking native actually.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Went there a little bit.
Freedom.
I'm driving.
Joey has always says that about our,
our pal Eddie Bravo,
Eddie Bravo.
We'll get a couple of drinks and get a little fucking great.
I Love Eddie Brown was my brother,
but uh,
Eddie,
Eddie Bravo even adopt the phrase Joey Dee has called that when the Indian comes
out,
because South Americans are essentially like Mexicans and especially our
Indians.
Right.
Mixed with Spaniards that came in like they didn't originally apparently speak.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean the,
in Spaniards,
the ink is in the Spaniards.
I mean that is like,
that's the root of a lot of people from Mexico.
That's why there's like Spaniard,
like Oscar de la Jolla,
right.
Looking Mexicans and then there's a double Hawkins.
That's more of a,
well,
there's some Mexicans.
It looked very native American right now.
Yeah,
but that's what Joey Diaz,
you say the Indians coming out,
fucking Indians coming out.
It's an Indians and they're notorious issues with alcohol.
Dude,
my,
My,
you've raised your hand like,
well,
I'm,
I'm my grandmother is half Ojibwe Chippewa Indian.
Do you get money from the casino?
I know,
not the casino,
but like if I wanted to go to school and like live on a reservation,
I could receive the benefits.
I know I'm white as goat cheese,
but it's true.
Half a grandma's my grammy almost half.
So mom's a quarter.
Yeah.
So I'm pretty much junk after like two drinks a fucking waste.
They're an eighth.
How many?
Yeah.
Wow.
Do you get money up to you?
Like a 16th right?
Um,
nobody getting money.
That's,
that's very complicated.
Like you have to be sort of in,
you have to live on a reservation.
You have to be willing.
No,
I want one.
I thought about it,
but I'm,
I'm in Los Angeles.
I don't want to move back to Minnesota.
You go to the tumor.
Not that I lived in Minnesota ever,
but that's where a lot of my family is from here.
Oh,
there's a couple of reservations.
There's the casinos.
She are owned by native Americans.
I know that,
but I didn't realize it.
Funny.
Here's,
you got a fun track.
I got a fun fact to you.
It's actually an unfun fact,
but in the state of California,
in the casinos,
why do I know this?
Because I like to gamble.
You can't throw dice.
It's illegal to throw dice in the state of California.
So,
um,
if you want to play craps,
which I love to play,
they,
they have a deck of cards and they flip two cards and then you,
you know,
attribute that too.
Yeah,
it's gross.
Let's you to use cards and all the guys read man.
What's going on?
Are we going to live?
There's,
there's just fighter jets everywhere.
I'm telling you it's red.
Don,
did you want to shore all the way back in fighter jets,
La there's,
there's a lot of,
there's people are like,
hey,
we're hearing all these fighter jets.
And then in San Francisco there was a couple at a couple of,
now ours,
we have to accept the fact that we're doing some creepy shit and other countries
and if it comes back to haunt us,
look,
these people are s slowly showing up with a bowler.
The guy in Dallas died,
someone else is,
uh,
is a nursing Spain.
Someone flew.
I mean,
but in this country,
I'm not going to Spain,
sorry,
my fault.
They,
some woman just came here from a,
I think it was Liberia or something like that,
and she has a in Los Angeles
lease advise motorists to avoid portions of westside do to Obama visit.
So it might be that he's here still
the power that that dude travels around with.
Well did that position,
you know she was Mitt Romney,
but at the same power.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not attributing it to him.
But we were talking to a friend,
we were talking.
What's he been doing about it?
Is Reading the Mormon Bible.
Let's talk about that.
Fine.
You know,
think you do know.
It's,
you think you know what he thinks you don't.
He didn't say.
If you had to guess,
what do you think he was thinking?
If you had to think,
what do you think you'd be thinking right now?
Well,
I wouldn't play guitar.
No.
Obama wielding power.
What are you going to say?
Yeah,
I was talking to him.
It's okay.
You guys are just both polite.
That's why this is awkward.
We're nice.
One of you was a bulldog.
He's just control this conversation.
There's this kid in junior high,
that fucking motherfucker,
he had a crush on you.
Of course he did.
Was He now bad game?
Why didn't you develop sooner?
Well,
here's what you're to need to learn about a lot of dudes.
Nobody teaches us how to talk to girls.
We just sort of have to figure it out when we're 13 when we do a terrible job
for the first seven or 14 years of our lives and then somewhere around 30 slowly
girls date older guys and then you get into trouble while you better than when
you make some lists.
Your poach.
It's what I was talking about with writing before earlier.
I think he's just letting it flow slip too worried about it now.
You calculated looking for Mrs Ben.
I'm getting better.
Better.
How about where you were at your worst when you're like,
I've hit rock bottom probably 24 25 we'll be doing kind of like an air of
desperation and everything.
I said,
you know,
I've never had like the single years.
You know what I mean?
I've always been like,
go on girlfriend and his girlfriend.
Yeah,
that's what a single years are great if you're successful,
but if you're unsuccessful,
it's horrible and lonely.
It can be very sad.
And there's also that sort of like stigma of like,
I'm the man,
I need to take the lady out and impress her,
but it's like sleeping on my friend's couch for two months.
Do you want to go out?
Yeah.
There's that.
Also that thing that you realize,
like when you're really struggling as an artist,
I guess as a musician,
definitely as a comedian it's very similar,
but you don't,
you know,
you know
nothing pure wits go along way.
I think that if,
if wherever you're at and who you are and where you're going is up to where
you're going is up to whatever,
I don't
fucking know.
But
the ether
playing guitar.
Yeah,
sure.
Buddha,
but,
but you know,
when you meet somebody that's like,
I think you're fucking awesome.
I don't,
I don't care that you're not where you want to be financially or professionally.
I think you're awesome.
That's the best time check on that motherfucker.
Definitely.
When was the last time?
Oh Man.
Where's your clothes?
Brush your fucking Weirdo.
Oh Man,
you're wearing my deodorant.
Go ahead.
Sorry man.
I did it.
Two guys that wear women's deodorant.
I like it.
So I was like peaches,
but I wear men's deodorant,
so take that for what?
Of Men's deodorant
in my purse.
Brian Calendar.
So clean.
Brian Callen just told me about some natural dealer to try.
He said it's like an aloe vera based deodorant that really works.
It's a natural healer.
He and he's the first one to tell you that natural deodorants are most,
most of the time,
their bullshit last long.
Usually it's usually they last a couple of hours.
It depends how smelly you are.
I'm just thinking one of the four yard he went to them
strong enough for a man made for men.
Yeah.
I'm not
strong enough for man,
but made for a woman.
No,
no.
If I put it on this going to be problems.
Okay.
What type of problems?
Like my
smell will go to war.
That wimpy ass fucking flower.
Refute Bullshit.
No,
I understand.
But not strong enough for a man.
But made for a woman.
What was that like?
Sure.
What secret secret.
Secret.
It's showing the,
it's made for a woman.
Isn't that funny how like one advertising slogan like that can just fucking give
a hoot.
Don't pollute that stuck.
Don't taste the rainbow.
Ooh.
It's the real thing.
Coke,
the real thing.
It'll clean your car battery,
that's for sure.
A Coca Cola yesterday,
which I hadn't had ears drain the whole thing when you weren't there
kind of bed.
Honestly,
I wasn't into it.
When we find out that some people drink like eight or nine of those in a day,
you know more on the road you see,
you see truckers come in with like a fucking big gulfs like the whole thing and
they'll fill the whole thing up with mountain doing the whole time.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Cancer.
Like I just think about that.
I was driving across the country recently.
Some truckers,
I love everybody,
don't drink that shit.
Just drink water and then drink beer later.
The good step and saying that for years I was looking at the back of some
truckers truck,
new advertising for more drivers and they said 50 cents a mile or something and
the average is 6,000 ma you can't exceed a certain mileage limit.
And I realize what these dudes are doing.
Cause sometimes I actually think about this cause we drive so much and I'm like,
if this doesn't work out,
what am I qualified to do music?
It's what I meant.
I can be a truck driver,
honestly,
because I've driven so fucking much that sometimes I think about that coming to
my head.
Um,
and why do you think about that?
Think about that.
You know,
I dunno.
Just like a residual.
Hey Man,
you've got to like a,
a fear,
you know,
residual fear from saying,
okay,
you're confronting something like
nat unnatural thing.
You know what I mean?
I'm going into a risky thing and we,
we could sell pizza together.
I honestly think about that sometimes to work at Santos Pizza.
That's part of the reason I've invested in you so much because I know this does
the backup contingency,
honey.
Honey band.
Follow them on Twitter and Instagram.
Honey,
honey band it.
Don't stop talking.
They want you to love them,
but speaking of advertisements,
what you want to talk about it?
It's fine.
We should talk about it.
A tour.
He guys battling it out right now.
This is it,
dude,
right now.
Joe,
you don't even know.
Fucking real man.
I don't want to hear that.
I want to think that you guys are the way you are when you hear all the time.
I want to think that you are the way,
the way everybody was on cheers and the shadow around the bar.
I don't want to think that anybody goes description.
Antidepressants was the taxi taxi.
What are you talking about?
Go Watch the [inaudible].
Wait,
no,
his wife was in shit.
Goddammit,
you were born in 1995 that's when I graduated from high school.
That was 17 you were a baby and I was like,
hi baby.
Oh my God,
you.
We're pretty 30 now.
You both beautiful.
Hey,
thanks babe.
Looking good.
I think you do too.
Honestly,
very symmetrical.
Thank you.
I feel symmetrical
but geometry is off though.
What do you mean?
Can I ask?
Can I completely,
I completely fucking take a left hand turn here.
This is,
this is something,
cause I think a questions in my life and honestly,
you're the only dude I can think of that might answer them.
Here it comes from gay shit again.
You know what?
Now you've made me timid.
I'm going to take a second.
Marijuana cause next 20 minutes.
You know a lot about this.
We have enough.
We'd,
if it ends in the next 20 minutes,
if it goes more than an hour,
we're going to have to go outside Brogan's character.
We're going to have to call speed.
Okay.
Oh that was a great movie.
Goddammit.
Will respond.
Rated movie.
Right?
Fucking what's his name?
Eastbound and down.
Dan and Brian,
he's the man.
He's the man.
Marries one of my favorite people.
Ever love that guy.
I would love to.
He probably wouldn't do it,
but if he did,
I'd hug him.
Where you kiss him on the mouth.
Fuck yeah.
God cast.
I believe you in the mouth to get you back on the podcast.
I'll kiss you on the fucking question.
I might have a weak question.
I saw your lower lip just
become derailed.
What's your question?
Or do you empty?
You guys argue before you got here was a really good day.
Like Ice Cube Alexa.
Oh my God.
I don't even care about,
what was your question?
So I used to smoke a ton of wheat.
Oh,
just too much.
What happened?
I don't feel like this is a safe space.
It doesn't feel like a safe space anymore.
I'm confused.
Am I on a play on it?
Hey guys,
sorry.
Stick up for me.
You Airwolf right out that door.
You know it doesn't help.
Suzanne,
I love you so much.
Yeah.
You know,
it doesn't help a lot when I've got him.
I'm being misogynistic when I'm struggling in a,
in you come up and save me.
You know,
it's kind of like,
oh
no,
no.
That's a little,
besides gender.
Sam was a man.
If you were were Sam instead of Suzanne and a man had a save you every time you
fucking hit the wall and the drain would have topped out,
he'd be like,
what the fuck?
First of all,
I think you need to let go of that.
We're partners so we take care of each other and I know you can answer.
If I were a dude I was like,
Yo Bro,
my fucking dude's got something to say.
Brody Stevens is 84% gay.
Who's Brody?
And you don't know who that is either.
Just fuck ups.
Is that,
is that your dad?
You might as well be.
I'd love him like a father.
What's your question?
Okay.
Okay,
so it didn't smoke weed for a while and I do every once in a while and I feel
like I get a cognitive boost when I do it.
Am I crazy?
No.
What is that?
What element of marijuana slash THC is doing that?
Well,
it's like cocaine.
Ps shot that there's a rule.
Ben Can't smoke weed when we're working cause he's like,
you want to do this?
Just just to,
just to frame the situation.
I,
if we have to do an all night drive,
I'll smoke because I can't fall asleep.
Fine.
Literally,
if I smoke be about five hours before I go to sleep.
Well,
I would imagine it's because the way your body reacts to cannabis is that your
body,
your creativity starts to fire up and your,
your,
your mind starts to embrace different possibilities then you would do if you
were sober.
It relaxes your inhibitions a little and lets you pursue ideas that maybe
because of the fact that you're in this precarious position in your career and
your life and that you're constantly filled with anx.
Like most 30 year old men may not shine easy.
Fuck.
47 47 I'm filled in some 47 you guys fucking dude it,
but red bands.
40 he gets some youthful motherfucker,
but we don't work.
Oh right.
We have real jobs is the toughest.
Nothing.
Nothing done.
I'm telling you,
I don't.
What's a real job?
Listen,
this is what a real job.
A real job.
No,
no,
no.
Trust me.
A real job was doing something you don't want to do,
but you do it anyway.
We don't have real jobs.
That's fine.
Do you have a real job,
a real job?
I'm not a real job.
There's no real jobs here.
There's no real job.
So that's a big part of aging is to regret and despair.
You're not in the weeds anymore.
You're smoking.
Weed's perfectly said,
perfectly said.
That's the perfect way to say it.
And my point being,
um,
everybody who,
who smokes weed,
who doesn't smoke very often has a big,
it has a big impact on you.
W marijuana is one of those things where it hits you when you don't do it a lot.
It hits you harder,
faster and more profoundly because you have these things in your brain,
allegedly,
apparently from what I've read called cannabinoid receptors that are literally
designed to accept the,
the influence of cannabis.
And then that's what they're there for.
And it comes from just gigantic history of human beings consuming cannabis.
If these cannabinoid receptors are also fired,
they believe when people do like long distance running,
like jogging,
like people say they get that runner's high,
it has a similar sort of enough endorphins.
Well,
there's a bunch of different things that happened inside the mind.
There's different neurotransmitters that get activated.
There's dopamine and Serotonin,
a lot of those or exercise related,
but a lot of those are also related to the consumption of psychedelic plants and
marijuana is a big one.
It's a giant part c.
We have this fucking idea that everything that is the way it is from the time
that we've been alive and our parents had been alive and the fucking just say no
to drugs from the Reagan administration was there.
That this is the way the world has always been.
It's not.
The world has been about consuming cannabis for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years,
but we're growing up in a society where fucking financial interest to figured
out a way to control the consumption of gigantic amounts of people.
The consumption of one of the most fantastic plants the world has ever known.
So when you do get ahold of one and it fires you up and you start thinking about
shit and you're flying through space,
you have all these ideas what it is,
is it because it's awesome.
That's why.
That's the only reason why you smoke it and you just can't shut the fuck up
cause you driving across country.
Those are thoughts that you're caging up in your mind.
Like you're fucking like you got a Pinata of ideas and you come along with a
hatchet and the hatchet and is,
it's in the shape of a joint and you fire up that joint and just shop away at
that stupid fucking fake elephant and candy comes pouring out and that candy is
these ideas that you've been sort of containing in your mind and storing up and
processing with no outlet and just just chemically,
chemically what's doing that.
Like what you have to re,
I'm obviously not a neuroscientist.
Oh okay.
Probably have brain damage.
You shouldn't do it.
I would suggest if I wasn't
me,
I would say don't listen to that dude.
He's probably got a couple good ideas that he memorized some website,
but everything else is most likely nonsense.
So we should do is Google Google the marijuana is affecting the mind and just
there's a lot of bullshit out
that's there.
There's a lot of,
I mean he has,
I think it affects everyone.
Very different.
Yes.
So you know,
which is the same street that we could smoke together.
Yep.
Hi.
Is it though?
Because that's everything.
Peanuts.
Some people,
yeah.
but I think that's a minority.
That's a tiny mine.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
come on.
No,
it's not a minority.
It's a minority in terms of it's less than a hundred percent of the population
is less than 50% it's probably less than 10% of people who are allergic to like
whatever cats.
There's people that will die if they in the room filled with cats.
Yeah.
You know,
firing diversity's real
well.
It's like,
it's like you could drink a glass of wine and be fine.
You could drink a glass of vodka and be a fucking lunatic.
Every,
it's know your body receives these things.
Is,
is complex.
And you know,
but that's just alcohol by volume,
you know,
what is your address?
Glass of wine or a certain amount of glass of vodka has much more.
Yeah.
Well it's just basically talking about what you were just saying is that every
person is different.
Everything affects them differently.
Definitely.
I'm really sensitive to weed.
Do you get high just being in this room?
I'm fucking off my rocker right now.
Also,
I'm kind of drunk.
It's hard to tell a little dry actually.
Yeah.
But I have to pee.
Go Pee.
Okay.
Whenever I talk about being stolen I go like this.
Do,
do,
do.
Um,
bum bom,
bom bum,
bum,
bum bum.
Bom De
is that the band's back together.
Tom.
Dump on pal
in the sunshine.
Yeah.
No
beautiful man.
That is a beautiful,
yeah.
Um,
but I think it affects you,
but to answer your question in all earnestness,
I think it's just cause you don't do it a lot.
Okay.
I can accept that,
but it's,
I just got curious about what I take time off.
It does that.
Okay.
I'm just curious about what specific processes happening to make me feel like,
Holy Shit.
I actually have access to all these different thought patterns.
Now.
You know I don't,
let me give you some advice for a friend.
Yes,
yes,
please turn on comes.
Don't question how I got my Dick
so hot.
Just accept the fact I got the picture.
Your penis is in fact ready.
Don't think of pills.
Okay.
Look,
your body is learning so much is flowing in a wash of chemicals.
This is it.
Your fault that the baby Jesus did not bless you with the proper Dick Chemicals.
No,
it is not.
I just gotta.
I gotta live with what I got.
I don't have to live with what you got.
What he got smarter then the Creator people have figured Viagara via,
you know,
the Creator said,
listen,
I want you to hit about 52 53 and you Dick's,
Jenna,
punch out desk.
No,
that's the best.
Says my dad is 63 when he had me.
Do you watch him?
Fuck
every time.
Takes every single time.
It probably takes bamboo and ties it to his dick.
Stretches it out to keep it hard then tapes it and place.
Thank you for saying that.
When you watch them,
do you just look back at it?
I hate it.
It's kind of like seeing my own future.
He's on tape and kite string.
He just keeps his cock.
No,
but I'm serious.
I'm
proud of my dad about,
honestly,
because I'm a very old dad.
My Dad's super fucking old.
How old is he now?
80.
Nope,
a thousand.
Almost
92.
93.
Oh my God.
And he's doing well.
He just broke his hip,
but he's okay.
He's doing great man.
Cause he's keeping his,
uh,
seriously.
He has all the way there.
He's with you.
You know what I mean?
And he's keeping the attitude.
He recognizes that if he gets depressed,
which is totally reasonable,
the fact that if he falls down,
which is what happened,
he tripped,
fell down to fucking broke the ball off of his hip just by falling down.
His bones are that brittle.
Whoa.
But he knows that if he accepts that as,
I dunno,
a serious of things,
as some people might,
he's done.
He's literally done.
You know,
so he's with it,
man.
Wow.
He's positive.
He's feeling good.
That's our all of our future.
I mean,
we're all going to be 93 if we don't get hit in the head by a fucking media or
if those jets don't mean business because it could be it.
This could be the last day.
I would've enjoyed it.
That's one of the big problems with being a person is that we all have the
ability to understand that are finite.
We all know it,
we rationalize it,
we have in our head,
but it never sort of reaches our immediate consciousness.
It always sort of sits in the periphery,
is some future possibility.
Well,
you know what I think is the,
the trickling down of that mindset is us looking at our times as specific as
unique in terms of how desperate things are or how close we are to the edge of
something.
You know,
the idea that like,
okay,
we're at the,
this is it.
You know,
they all look at all this chaos in the world.
I think it's always been like that,
but our way of communicating with mortality is saying no,
this time is unique.
Well,
this time is unique though.
Well of course it's unique in the sense that events that are happening now,
I've never happened before that.
I think that's the number one draw of and I mean it's nice to be nostalgist and
nostalgic and look at it in like in,
in,
in relationship to the Times that we're unique in the 70s and the 60s and the
forties there every time has been the pinnacle of human interactions at this
moment.
Right now at 2014 we are at the front of the line of what it is to be a person
and we really are.
We were at the front,
we're at the front with phones or the front with social media or the front with
with this,
this,
this is fucking crazy podcast.
What we're doing right now.
These the,
the ability to talk to people like do you really be Ben?
You really be Suzanne.
Be really be me,
Brian.
Brian is sort of him,
but even he is confused as to what the fuck is going on.
Why you look fucking amazing.
We just learned that Brian's,
he's a sexy bitch skin,
like a newborn stash hair.
Even the weight of it's got to cook woman.
His life should go to dinner.
He doesn't have a job.
I have a show after this.
I'm doing the Ice House in Pasadena and then I'm doing the Improv.
Does this mean we're not hanging out after work?
And I know we just gotta get my 22nd what you just said,
Ben,
calm down.
Sorry.
We're in the same town.
W what?
I just what you were just saying about like where we're at right now.
Yeah.
Evolved and we're on this podcast and we're talking,
we're speaking in,
in our truth in our own way.
Right.
That gives me hope because you know,
all of the sort of like sanitize media and the things that you are,
are,
um,
given on a regular basis and the information that's coming through.
I'm always doubtful.
I'm always weary and nervous and doubt,
you know,
I just don't believe it.
Right.
I mean,
I'm sure there's some actual,
you know,
reality to it,
but I think there's always an agenda with major media market and whatever.
We were talking about different things here.
No,
no,
no.
But as far as,
um,
you know,
you were talking about like the current state of our mortality and,
and you know,
our,
our visual of like,
Ooh,
it's really bad.
Or it's how it,
how it is.
I think that,
um,
the,
the way that we perceive the world now you have options and options like
podcasts or are really learning about someone else's viewpoint from there,
like right out of the horse's mouth.
Um,
on a podcast that's not funded by,
you know,
a major oil company or something,
right.
That,
that's where I feel a little more comfort and I'm,
am I confusing anybody?
No.
We're
having this conversation.
We're friends and it doesn't matter if we're doing a different thing that we
would be doing if we were just hanging out because we know that people are
listening.
So we're doing this different thing where we're trying to be like really clear.
We're trying not,
you're doing a great with much try not to talk over Suzanne,
just not get it.
That it's okay.
But what we're doing is there's no other influences of the nos.
We know what we're doing.
We w we have this idea that,
okay,
we're,
we're putting out something that people are going to receive and it's going to
be entertaining.
And we have our binder biases.
You know,
we are,
we're in a band.
We'd signed a record deal.
I was shit,
but we're not,
I understand what you're saying.
I think I'm just trying to be super literal as Tom.
Sorry.
No,
even think it's not,
it's like,
it's,
we do this all the time.
So it's a weird form of expression,
right?
It's weird form of expression when you,
you're talking,
but you also know that people are listening,
you know?
Um,
but the beautiful thing is there's no interruptions and no one is telling you
yes or no.
Like there's no publicist is standing over your shoulder saying,
this is bad for your career.
There's no go bean counter.
Who's saying,
listen,
Ben,
if you admit to gay thoughts and wanting to kiss Brian Redman,
I'm the mouth because it was beautiful mustache.
This is going to cost us 14 records,
an hour worth it worth every penny.
They might fucking break and see that as a bad thing.
14 people are.
Cons is no free lunch.
Fucking shitty.
Let me express my love.
Never losing my country charm or my fucking fanny pack.
Both of those things stay to the,
to the grave.
You have a fanny pack,
chuck.
Do I sell them?
Yes I do.
If I run out of them.
Yes.
primate.com selling coffee.
No,
this is my buddy.
This is just no interest in this business.
I mean other than the friendship interest,
no financial.
We talked last time about bulletproof coffee.
Caveman coffee is my friend Tate.
And uh,
my friend Keith Jardine,
they have this company that they sell single source coffee from this farm.
It's Colombia and Nicaragua.
I think it's,
I want to say Columbia,
but uh,
it's just the fucking salt of the earth.
Those dudes are,
I love Keith and I'm Tate is my brother.
So I wear the shirt.
It's a good look how to respect wired loyalty.
Wait,
where's your show?
Because yeah.
You want to come?
Yeah.
I'm got the ice house at yeah.
At eight and then a,
I'm at the Improv.
10 o'clock shows you work.
I'm working on some new shit,
so I got to bang out some new jokes.
I'm trying.
My comedy Central Special Airs November 21st so I'm in this weird scramble
trying to reconstruct the scaffolding of my next hour right now.
It's like the really exciting,
thank you so much,
man.
Thank you for you.
Put our song in it.
Oh,
dude.
Yeah,
of course he did.
I picked it.
That song.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the beginning trailer is,
is me asleep and a field in the mountains of Colorado and your songs playing in
the background.
I run to the,
thank you so much next week.
Oh.
Snappa like you hired it.
Where are you going to say?
Where are you guys up?
We're planning a story in a play in the lounge and Denver and then beaver creek,
which is,
oh shit.
Beaver creek.
We're going to Texas.
We're going to New Mexico or Louisiana.
Hey,
all we end up,
we end in,
in um,
in California here in Los Angeles on November 1st.
What is in California?
What is it?
Our let our last show of the tour.
Do you want to come?
If I'm here,
hold on.
November.
Hold on.
You want a party?
It's a Saturday.
Listen,
we gotta be really careful one day after Halloween,
so you have to take your,
your monkey suit off time.
Was it my monkeys?
Never for our time.
November 1st.
We want you exactly as you are you sorry.
I'm going to be in.
We should,
um,
we should,
we should go hunting.
Do another show together cause that'd be really fun.
Fuck yeah.
I mean we did the one December 21st,
2012 so that was like,
it was a while,
almost two years ago.
I was so excited because bill burr was backstage and I just love him so much.
I love him so much too.
Came down to hanging out with us.
He's great.
He's awesome.
He's a sweet guy too.
He's a really,
really genuinely good guy.
Like,
you know like for for comics like to see other comics that are like really
supportive and friendly is so important.
So he just showed up to hang out with me and Joey and Dunkin and you guys.
I don't know him personally.
No person,
man.
I hear good things.
Yeah,
but I don't know him too much.
I don't hang out with them.
Maybe do a double podcast,
whatever,
whatever you want to do it.
Two years after the end of the world show,
that would be fucking pretty bad ass
years.
Like Mayans were wrong x 24 months,
although we don't know because those fucking fighter jet that just went over,
hey,
what's going to happen
to run out of gas?
They're going to have to land people overwhelming with slingshots.
Yeah,
I know.
If the world ended and we were right here,
be cool.
Joe,
was all of your adventures that you go on space shuttle,
is that on the docket?
Put some fucking ice and whiskey in that class.
He's talking about this shit.
This is what I think they think.
I'm available for space travel about a decade into successful space.
Travel for civilians,
meaning once Richard Branson has hit the 2029 marks and like pretty much no
one's dying.
Hilarity would have come at that.
Let them get all the kinks out.
You know what I mean?
Iron that shirt out.
Let those overeager motherfuckers think I remember that.
Yeah.
Well how about the people?
There's over a hundred thousand people that have signed up as potential people
to live on more or be the first people to move to Mars.
No,
he made it.
How do you do that?
You just breathe in.
I think it's a male face and it makes different noises.
Scared
needs pills.
Could you imagine if you move to Mars and you found a fucking sign you were
digging,
like trying to plant tomatoes.
I think sign that said,
get the fuck out of here quick.
Do you guys remember that with ice cube and it was about like Mars.
Fuck.
What was it called?
Friday
and people die.
Oh,
it was a John Carpenter movie.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I remember seeing that when I was young teenager.
God,
I don't remember too much about that,
but there's some Mars movie kind of like a Zombie.
It feel to it.
Well,
the idea of Mars,
to me,
it's like living in the shittiest neighborhood of all time.
There's no plants,
there's no la air quality.
Can't go outside and even breathe the air.
You relying on human inventions
for,
how about the rest of your life,
bitch,
not you.
The person,
the person on the,
on the island of Mars itself.
You know the really scary thing about Mars is when they keep finding all this
water on it,
they keep finding all these like former rivers and former lakes and it makes
you,
it really cemented in your head that like earth could be just like that one day.
Look,
we could get hit with not like what killed all the dinosaurs,
but something fucking crazier.
You can get hit with some instead of five miles wide.
Well,
yeah,
that can happen.
Hyper Novas like in a nearby galaxy just cooks everything.
And some sometimes asteroidal impacts planets collide and the fucking entire
atmosphere of the planet changes.
That's not just common.
It's the standard every fucking planet.
If you look at the moon,
if you look at Earth,
everything is littered with,
oh yeah.
Impacts every planet we've are found littered with astro people actually robots.
Do you think that uh,
we have the technological capacity to prevent that kind of thing cause cause
we'd know it was coming at this point or at least there's a good chance of it.
This is what I think.
Tell me everything other than what is absolutely positive that we can do,
whether it's air travel,
whether it's a travel into space,
space stations is essentially theoretical.
Sure.
Unless we've done it,
they don't know we can do it.
They assume that we can get away with going to Mars,
but it could
very well be that they get out into deep space and they find out that the
magneto sphere and the,
the,
the fucking,
the atmosphere of the earth is protecting us his way in ways from like long
trips that we just don't understand the possible risks,
especially radiation asteroids,
micro meteors what?
Sure.
You and your hands up.
Yes.
From honey honey.
What is the magnetosphere?
The,
well there's,
there's a surface.
Okay.
The of the earth,
right?
You got your dirt,
you got your water,
you know,
you got you what you can touch.
And then above it you have various layers of gases.
You have oxygen,
you have the magneto sphere,
you have,
um,
you have uh,
an ozone you had,
there's a bunch of things that surround the earth.
Here's one of the layers of the earth made of guy would do a piss poor job of
describing it because obviously my education is before,
but essentially what's going on is you have the atmosphere of the planet and it
goes from say like one inch.
You know,
like the touching the ground too,
you know,
x amount of miles up into the sky until we essentially start calling it space.
And then from there on you have the van Allen radiation belts,
which engulf the earth,
these radiation belts,
which you know,
or like a doughnut shaped like band of radiation than in circles the earth.
And then outside of that you have deep space and there's no protection out
there.
All that other stuff,
the atmosphere,
all the other stuff protects us from things like gamma rays from solar flares,
from um,
supernovas if like there was some sort of a supernova in a nearby galaxy and
gamma rays when flying through the fucking galaxy stuff that's unique to earth
or to no planets in general,
neither the atmospheres we know for a fact is atmosphere is in many planets and
many different solar systems that we found throughout the universe,
including binary Solon systems,
which means they have two different stars.
And then there's,
we've also detected simple gasses,
like different gases that that exists on earth,
whether it's hydrogen or oxygen.
We,
they've detected those on a lot of planets.
Now.
It was just a dick a decade ago when they didn't know how many planets there
were out there.
It was just guessing,
but now they're just spotting them left and right and they,
a lot of it,
they spot the star and then they see the wobble of the star and they recognize
that something is spinning around the star and that's something most likely as a
planet.
And then they can determine the mass of the planet and then they can zoom in on
that spot and find out if it's got hydrogen or oxygen or whatever the fuck is on
that plan.
The likelihood that there are other planets like ours and there it's 100% it's
this is what's really fucked up.
It's not only is there most likely other planets like us,
but from the way it's been explained to me,
the universe is so big that if infinity is real and there's no reason to believe
that it's not wood.
Infinity means if the universe truly has no boundaries,
and if there's infinite numbers of universes like the same,
the same idea exist an infinite number of times,
like an unmeasurable,
impossible number that there's another Suzanne and other Ben out there sitting
on these shitty office Max Leather chairs,
comfy
nipple rings in a Dick.
Why not just switch it up?
Guarantee you.
There's another Suzanne out there with a deck that has eyeballs and it's like
big Dick.
Every possibility that you could think of exists.
This is what's really fucked up about the concept of infinity.
Infinity literally means there's no boundaries,
there's no end.
So it's not like you get to a certain amount of time.
The raw carbon building blocks for life.
We've run out,
we've made all the giraffes and the fucking cactuses and the palm trees.
We don't have any room for us who's hand with a giant Dick and incorrect.
We have another fucking infinite number of universes with infinite solar
systems,
infinite galaxies,
and inside one of those somewhere a billion,
trillion fucking zillion miles away.
There's another Suzanne.
But this is coming from a point of complete,
not complete,
but like a,
a decent amount of ignorance,
but what can you get to speak English?
So I was under the impression that there's still the understanding that the
universe is contracting Doosan degree,
what's supposed to be currently expanding but will eventually contract.
But,
but that speaks to,
uh,
perimeters.
Well,
the problem is when you talk about this kind of stuff,
especially if it's a guy like you who's a musician or a gog means an idiot.
We're really,
we don't know what,
we don't know what the fuck you're saying.
So we're just basically parroting what we've heard.
Like legitimates,
degrass,
Tyson,
Michio Kaku,
astrophysicist type dudes actually like do the calculations and figure it out.
And I think that,
um,
there's a lot of debate about what we know and what we're sure of.
And sometimes those things come into question.
Like lately there's a guy,
there's a new guy who is claiming that black holes don't exist.
And this is like a really recent study that a lot of people are taking very
seriously.
And this guy has said that black holes as we know them do not exist because it's
kind of showing this room though.
What's that?
Five in this room?
Five black holes is not black.
It's not even Brown.
It's like a red.
You should get that looked at.
Here's it.
Here it is.
This is the theory.
Black holes do not exist.
But think about it like the big bang.
This did not.
The big bank did not exist a hundred years ago,
a hundred years ago,
and people riding around on horses and fucking doing any Oakley fucking shooting
galleries with,
oh,
like looking at a fucking mirror and shooting over their shoulder.
It was a greatest thing you could ever do that.
No one knew what the fuck the big bang was.
No one had any idea why the stars were in the sky.
And now we know.
But this guy,
this recent guy,
uh,
or,
excuse me,
it's a woman.
What?
Then of course I'll only wrong would try to take away the bay.
You fucking bitch.
I'm sorry ma'am.
I do it.
I was only kidding.
Boy.
Her,
her name is professor Laura Mursine.
H O.
How can I help tone?
How often said she is still in shock from the fine.
Uh,
previously scientists thought the stars were much larger than the sun collapsed
under a,
their own sons collapse under their own gravity and formed black holes when they
died.
And during this process they release a type of radiation called Hawking
radiation.
But new research claims the star would lose too much mass and wouldn't be able
to form a black hole.
And if this is true,
the theory that the universe began as a singularity followed by a big bang could
also be wrong.
I don't understand a word you said,
it's quite interesting,
but by the dissolution of historic can't have this ultimately dense,
ultimately small,
infinitely dense,
infinitely small ball of matter,
which creates the big man.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't like,
is this where we're dumb and even bothering to have this conversation because I
think his shit is,
this is beyond like the great minds of our time.
This is one of those things where there's no conclusion.
That's contract.
Really started it.
Time to move in.
Yeah.
You guys want to set up the microphones to give her a guitar.
She wakes up.
She'll start singing like an angel.
I was with you the whole time.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm not even with me.
I don't understand it.
Here I'll do.
My question is when it says,
please,
when a huge star,
many times the mass of the sun comes to the end of its life,
it collapses in on itself and forms a singularity creating a black hole where
gravity is so strong that not even light itself can escape.
At least that's what we thought.
As scientist has sensationally said,
it is impossible for a black holes to exist and she even has the mathematical
proof to back up our claims.
I need to,
I should work at 14 and see true.
Her research could force physicist to scrap their theories of how the universe
began.
The research was conducted
by Professor Laura Marcy Ni.
How often from the University of North Carolina.
Oh,
I lost interest.
Did you say Harvard?
You didn't.
You say MIT.
I didn't hear that.
I heard the University of North Carolina
Ivy League in hard for what?
I said Umass Boston.
He went to Umass,
barely,
barely went to Umass Boston for three.
Holy Shit.
Wasted my time.
I only went when like the continuing education program.
I didn't even take my sats.
I the only reason.
Thank you.
I did good for you.
Okay.
Yeah.
You low lives parole,
living your life without proving yourself and 18 not doing that.
No.
Uber.
It's here.
It's real.
We have a driver.
It's also,
we have a number we lived on.
Um,
what do you think?
What were we talking about?
Proletariat.
Umass.
Boston's.
Yeah.
I went,
I only went because I was worried that people thought I was a loser when I got
out of high school.
I had no idea what it's going to do and I kept telling him,
but I'm just going to take a year off.
And what I would tell girls that they would look at me with such disdain.
Fuck,
that's what I did.
Absolutely.
You had to go to college because that's what everybody in your class did.
And if you said you weren't going or you didn't know by you graduated high
school,
people were like,
oh shit,
I didn't go.
I didn't experience that kind of discrimination.
But well,
it's not discrimination.
It's wanting you to live up to a certain quality of work ethic and standard.
Where I grew up,
I lived in Newton,
Massachusetts and Newton,
Newton,
Newton Mush,
Newton north,
they called each other mush.
It's one of the only places on earth where Mush like what?
Up Mush Mush.
You seen his fucking broad mush.
She's got a big ass mush cross didn't have big assets.
What else is,
it doesn't mean anything,
but there's an area of news called the lake.
The audible comma.
No,
no dude,
it's their version of dues.
It's their version of dude who do
it was mush when I grew up in,
I grew up in Newton south and I didn't get much.
But my good friends Kevin Chase on and my good friends nick to Teleo,
they both went to Newton north.
Okay.
Uh,
Newton North was different than Newton South Jimmy laws.
What's new south,
who's also my good friend.
And we,
uh,
his name is lawless.
Jimmy motherfucking Lawler.
Still my friend
Michael Law changes you.
That's his name.
Just like Getty Bravo.
That's another one of my friends.
More proof.
We're living in a simulation.
You guys are itching to rock this patient.
No,
you are.
I need to say anymore.
Bush was cool.
They were trapped.
They were living in a place where it snows six months out of the year.
Know I lived in Madison.
There was a prince song called sometimes it snows in April.
Yeah,
very sad song.
Sometimes it's snow.
It's also prince called song called.
Sometimes he feels so bad.
I was in my Audi Fox.
Okay.
I was coming home from my,
my gig where I was driving a private investigator that lost his job.
He lost his driver's license because he was Dui and he needed someone to drive
him around,
so he put out an ad in the want ads for an assistant for private investigator.
His name was dynamite.
Dickless Dave Dolan.
He's also still my good friend from Boston.
Look,
I wouldn't go back to Boston,
but that mother fucker shaped me.
Okay.
Anyway,
that's driving back in April.
Snellen listened to Prince.
Sometimes it snows.
And I was like,
I gotta get the fuck out of Boston
kid.
Deal with snow in April.
Like what'd you get bombed?
I got blues all the time.
I was a loser.
I think that that's fair.
Everybody does that.
Well if you're super desperate and you're trying to carve your path in this
world with a rabid desperation like I was,
you're always,
you're always feeling like shit.
Sure.
Cause if you're not feeling like shit,
you feeling complacent,
feel completion,
nothing gets done.
Well you know the,
the blues come and go like that.
That's just inevitable I think at this point.
And when you accept it and you figured out what it is and what it means and you
just keep,
you know,
under having an understanding with yourself and
oh it's important that a certain,
a certain type of people,
like people that you listen to,
like someone like you or like you or like you guys name their,
their reality,
like talk about the reality and talk about the blues and then everybody goes,
oh I get it.
It's just a part of struggling.
They can.
Part is struggling is,
but I think you guys are super talented and we've been friends for years now and
I've always thought you guys are super talented from the moment I saw that that
one song where you guys were on top of the roof and you were saying an angel of
death.
I love you guys so much too.
I think you guys are amazing.
But when,
when you,
when you connect with something like that and you see someone who's doing
something that like makes you like,
it makes you feel good when you see it and you want to spread it to these other
people,
it's like what?
What,
what is that?
What that is at the,
at its best it's like this is weird light that you can find the deep dark
tunnels of human creativity that makes you feel better about the struggle.
I like the fact that you guys haven't made it.
I'm really
sorry.
I'm not,
I wish you had made it.
I wish you were multi-multi multimillionaires.
I think,
and I know that it's come to and I know you're not going to change then I buy
shit.
You say love
you guys.
When you were in the fucking,
you were in the God damn roots of it all.
You were swinging,
you know,
you guys are sleeping on couches and fucking jam out.
You guys did that December 21st show that we did at the Wiltern.
Yeah,
that kept us 2012.
Thank you.
Thank you that you guys fucking crushed it.
I'll never forget Joey,
Joey Diaz,
Eddie Bravo came backstage after you guys got off stage before a Dunkin went up
or Joey went up and uh,
he came up stage or was it?
Yeah,
it was Joey and then Doug Stanhope.
So before Joey went up,
you guys were on stage,
you were fucking killing it.
And Joey came backstage with Eddie Bravo and they're both shaking their head
back and forth and they just go,
that's bad ass bitch.
That is a bad ass.
Because they kept saying that and then Joey Goes,
God damn,
those motherfuckers are talented.
And a bravo was just shaking and said,
God damn,
those motherfuckers a talent.
And then they both go,
how are they not famous as fuck?
How would they not famous as fuck?
Like it became like a conversation before the rest of the show went on.
Like you,
you guys were just fucking crushing it.
I don't even remember what song it was,
but they were just,
Eddie Bravo was holding his hands on his head like the fucking home alone kid.
And he was saying,
he was like,
God damn,
they're really good.
And I go,
I told you dude,
they're really good.
He's such a nice dude.
They're both nice dudes.
Thanks man.
But if you're saying no,
that really sweet stuff,
I like the fact that I knew you guys when you went shit,
but you where you were,
but you weren't.
It's like I love the fact that there's something out there that's it's as good
or better than anything else,
but people don't know yet.
They don't know yet.
And you guys are out to just fucking chipping away at it.
And slowly people are going,
Whoa,
Lee.
Fuck.
And that's what happens in this world and it makes it better.
I honestly,
I,
I feel good about it.
You know what I mean?
I feel,
I feel all this all this time we're putting in now and who cares what happens on
Ben.
I don't picture you in bed with David.
Bowie is going to happen.
That shit happen tonight.
I know it's
taking a longer,
stronger row.
You get to know who you are by the time you get in bed with David Bowie and you
go,
you're going to go like call me.
I love the music.
I love,
I love your music.
I'm going to fucking give you a hug and I'm going to go home.
It's actually a express ourselves differently.
Mutual respect,
no touching.
I think it's super important to go through that struggle.
I think that if you guys had somehow or another like started out together and
then a week later someone came along and went,
Holy Shit,
you guys are fucking great.
Not
that,
but it didn't.
That's dead.
But that's what's so cool about,
like,
everyone has a different,
different way to get there,
you know,
different vehicle.
And,
um,
I think about that a lot because we've been through so much shit together.
We've been through so much in our personal lives and in the career.
Um,
and I,
I feel really lucky for that because I have so much information and experience
and understanding of what this business entails.
We've,
we've booked our own shows,
we've been around manager at times,
we've done all the shit,
you know,
and if,
if we had like blown up when we were young,
I don't know what would have happened.
That's a terrifying thought because,
you know,
we talk about this a lot,
but essentially like being good people and,
and,
and having a legitimate reason for doing this,
not like some mass predatory,
you know,
oh,
I would just want to be the best.
That's not why we play music.
And that's stupid.
And,
you know,
narcissistic.
Um,
we've had all these crazy experiences and,
and difficult times and,
and it was,
that's what he's done with Matt.
Does that mean
keep it
close to our goal?
I told you it was the end of the world.
The fighter jets.
Do you snore?
Jail.
Cow.
Oh my God.
I have to wear a mouthpiece.
Oh,
do you really?
What does that even mean?
What do you mean?
My neck is not a normal neck.
She's neck teaching the alien.
And that's supposed to be what?
A lot of wrestlers and people who do a lot of like moving their head around too
many muscles in your neck and your,
your tongue will fall over.
You're,
you're,
you're air hole.
Flog that bitch up.
So I wear a mouthpiece.
Damn.
You got to keep my tongue from falling back into my air hole and keep your lady.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We knew what that,
no,
I don't want to die either.
Sure.
Guys have died.
I know.
Okay.
Valid.
Yeah.
So can you sleep a few times?
Just give up like a bitch.
I used to,
uh,
my sister has sleep apnea and I used to live with her.
Oh,
let's talk about her.
She's great.
Hey,
you know what?
She's opening a juice shop in Cleveland and I support that.
What's it called?
I love juice shop daily press juice.
When is it up?
It's going to be up very soon actually.
Allegedly.
Allegedly dreams have failed in the past two days.
The shit out of her.
I'll tweet the show over.
Let me know.
Let me know when it's up.
She's so good.
I will pre Albin tweet,
tweet.
No,
we were fine.
Shut up.
I've only been to Cleveland once.
I'll go back.
Hey,
next time you're there,
you should meet my family.
They're really cool.
If you're in Cleveland,
we'll be there.
We'll make it a point to be there together and we'll have a party.
Let's do this.
How about we book a show cause you guys and me and Cleveland and we'll see if
Joey can do it too.
I love that so much.
I need to not invite my parents,
Jesus Christ,
keeping parents at home.
Where do we get funding to do this?
Including the state theater.
Would you guys aim for the stars?
Would you guys read you?
What do you think about your set?
Right?
What'd you guys do this?
Would you guys do your set and then play in the background?
While Joey's onstage and I'm onstage just fuck around and play music.
Louis Shit for that shit.
Just have fun.
Heck yeah,
that'd be,
it's done.
You're like jazz,
jazz
poetry.
Like the gay guy from Star Trek make it so.
Which one is that gray?
Kington no,
it's the
contemporary.
No,
the new one.
Not even the new new,
new new ones.
Fucking semi new one.
What's his name?
Three hours.
Cause it feels like a car.
No,
it's only six 30 this is amazing.
He's gay.
She's Gaydar is like from the 1950s and it runs on coal.
No,
Brian,
he just asked me if the fucking guy from star trek is gay.
Bald Guy.
Like do you not even pay attention?
You don't understand your surroundings.
What's that guy's name?
Patrick.
Patrick Stewart.
He's a beautiful man.
Him and Gandalf.
She gets together.
They probably have.
I think that,
yeah,
I think this picture is about that.
Good for them.
God bless them.
I'm going to give Jennifer Lawrence a hug.
If you're near her,
I want you to tell her it's going to be okay.
You're beautiful.
Don't worry about this
of you're naked.
You're beautiful.
Don't worry about it.
What's happened is Patrick's to a gay,
the Guardian falsely outs Captain Picard after he congratulates Ellen page and
coming out.
What year is this though?
Uh,
yesterday.
2011.
13 February 20th not be gay.
Okay.
Iris,
I hope.
I hope he's happy.
Who gives a fuck if he's gay?
Who gives a fuck?
Can you guys podcasts?
It is a,
you know what?
I'm a gay friendly person.
I'm also a trans
friendly person.
I really am.
Even though I don't want trans women beating the fuck out of CIS women.
I'm a trans friendly person.
I'm a
dwarf,
friendly person,
little people,
whatever it is.
I'm black,
friendly,
Filipino friendly,
Asian friendly,
white friendly,
straight male.
I'm loving it.
I love everybody.
I really do a lot of positivity that they were all locked up in conflict man.
And I think there could be a lot less of it.
And if there was,
we'd figure a lot more shit out and we get a lot more shit done and be nicer to
each other and make the whole experience just a little bit easier.
A little more.
Well,
Lou,
we're all in this together,
no matter who the fuck you are.
Bottom middle.
Fuck yeah.
I've been watching a lot of the teen feels so
I've been paying attention to a lot of people are,
this is over the line.
There's a process that happens when I put out a special,
um,
and one of the big things that happens is after specials out,
I scramble,
I go in this mad panic state where I have to come up with a bunch of new
material and it's good and it's bad.
I and yeah.
And it had some,
I sometimes the house from rough sets come to see me while I'm right working out
new shit.
Come a year later you'll be so happy.
It'll all work out.
But um,
along the lines of like doing all this,
I started exposing myself to a bunch of different things.
I try to expose myself to as many things as possible.
It's really scary.
It's scary to try to come up with new material and it's scary to tread down new
paths and not have formulated
bits so you can call upon the absolutely know they're going to be effective,
but that's what life is about.
But we'll just,
um,
just to,
to be some supportive friends here.
You're so fucking brilliant.
Like your,
your brain capacity.
She's got gay.
I thought it was going like two hours ago and talked about the guy g h e y like
protein,
like whey protein,
Gay Lakeway.
What's his,
and it's trying to say is we believe in you.
Believe me.
You guys too so important that you believe in me.
It's important that we believe in each other.
I believe I can fly my God space to answer.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
I'm not good with compliments.
Tried to shut them off whenever we feel secure with complimenting you and you
not accepting them.
They fucked me in the past.
I don't trust him anymore.
No,
come on.
Can you guys please staple you afterward?
I assume that was a part of our package deal and giving you guys on the podcast.
You know what?
I just realized I'm going to play this acoustic guitar.
I don't know if it's going to hit this microphone.
Hmm.
Should I do want to leave two microphones here.
Are you cool with that?
Okay.
I'm going to aim it at the 12th fret.
What?
Welding?
This piece of shit.
I think it's okay.
Jammer and no,
no,
it's not Jamie.
Fix it.
No,
no gravity.
It's a fake.
God dammit.
Jamie.
Jamie are so great.
How's it going?
This is drunk talk.
I'm a little tick.
I'm glad I don't have to drive further.
We might not make it through.
This will be fine and we love you.
Twitter's lighten up layer car.
God Damn Christmas tree right now.
They're so happy.
I can't hear anything.
I'm interest is authentic.
People love it.
Brian loves it.
I looked down the table.
He loves it.
Hard on no,
someone I met.
The is hard.
I mean it's feet were tapping.
Fuck Ben,
are you doing headphones?
I'm doing one in one out.
Okay.
Am I do one and two?
I'm not sure.
Oh that shut the fuck up and say,
okay.
You Ready?
Are we doing this now?
This punk kid.
Okay.
When you were young.
I bet you a park.
I bet you are.
Cause it takes one to know potty.
Yeah,
I'll bet you.
I bet you made your mom
sat in the cross ribbon cutting and Dan is sad.
She's a good one.
Ooh.
Feeling bad.
Feeling Bay.
How you do consumer along the line.
Somebody gave it to you
no matter how you do a field.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
MMM.
That was beautiful.
I don't know
when these little fantastic,
you don't need that shit.
I love that song.
I love fucking love that
song.
I've heard that song a hundred times.
Easily.
Easily without a doubt.
That's why I picked it.
I,
that's the song that I just like,
just like had this like cool fucking fun,
like riff to it.
I just,
I had to hear that song over and over and over again.
I played that song.
I'm not bullshitting.
I played that song close to a hundred times.
If I had to stop and guess I played at one time at the gym,
I put it on repeat and I got on the stair climber and I went to half an hour and
I listen to your fucking song for half an hour.
I was trying to figure out what song to use for the beginning of the special and
I had a bunch of your songs,
your old songs and new songs and uh,
and uh,
I listened to that song over and over again for half an hour is actually the
elliptical.
I misspoke on the stair climber me day.
I remember the joints allegedly,
I don't think stair climber is bad for the joints.
It just gives the joint some work.
Bitch ass joints cause of work.
Stop being scared.
Stop being scared of all elliptical and shit.
What else?
Yes,
I got electrocuted when that song started.
I don't know if it's that amp that's plugged into something and now I'm sorry
Brian,
does the gay coming out of your sweat so badly happens all the time.
So badly.
Not so bad.
Badly.
I know.
You feel so bad.
I'm working on it.
You know,
are you a grammar?
Yeah,
I actually really care about that stuff.
In what way do you accidentally,
right?
Y O u r when you met y o u apostrophe and you tweet it and you go,
fuck,
oh no,
I'm that's worth trashing a tweet and get it back up again.
I really care about that.
I'm not kidding.
Like twos and twos.
There's there's,
and there's all I know is all I care about don't write.
You are to me.
Are you lazy?
You can't like why are you scared that you don't know which one is y o u
apostrophe party while you are,
I don't think he's talking to you,
Suzanne.
I think it's kind of bringing it to a larger,
very rhetorical question,
but I'm confused.
What is the CSO?
Hi,
what do you think about Emojis,
Joe?
It'll be fine.
Everybody's going to be fine.
This is like the Cheshire cat.
That's a lot of like Allison.
This is the 1% of Pipe Jack.
We'd smoke.
I've told you at 47 smoking weed for a little while.
Joe,
we really want to talk about DMT or online.
Okay,
fair enough.
Cia High and let them know that I'm on the same fucking page.
Listen,
Bro,
I'm not an anti American.
I used to own a Mustang.
Well,
I need you people to know you did not personally.
Shelby gt 500
I'll fuck there.
You had a bunch of American cars right now.
I don't have currently any American cars.
Jesus.
What are we working with right now?
But,
but when we did this video for your song,
the punk kid song,
we used your riff.
I was driving a new shell.
One of those new dodge challengers.
Challenger Srt.
Hell cats.
How did you know it was the Dutch?
Because I pay attention.
God dammit.
I sent you an email.
Oh it me.
It was a tweet or a,
it was an Instagram.
I was there.
This an Instagram on a party.
Oh,
I didn't know.
Ben Wants to be a part.
We talked about this.
We've talked about this.
We've talked about,
what'd you talk about specifically?
Do you guys now you've tried to like Mary chicks that don't fuck
pretty much danger zone.
Look,
do you know what though?
We got Kenny Loggins up in this motherfucker.
Dangers?
No.
Oh my God.
Zero musical talent.
That's going to help
friends.
Just let friends be.
I Love Ben.
Okay.
I don't have anything invested in Ben.
Not fucking up his words.
No,
no,
no.
I'm great.
I'm going to be ultimately supportive and loving towards you.
Just cash you the weirdest nonsexual couple of sexual attention,
I think.
I think you guys just need,
as you might have to one day
you guys might wind up married.
Is that possible?
That's a one day you guys get super famous in fucking comment.
Flail away in the weeds.
Maybe 60 no,
forties 40 so we still have some action.
There's a certain number of years you can,
you can put on your body when no one wants to fuck you anymore,
unless you're like a class to make sure you're cool with it.
A spin.
You want to take this shit to the next level.
You'll be the old machine.
Will you fucking married?
Yeah,
I married people before
I'm,
I'm an ordained minister.
You're not kidding.
Like one of those online training,
ww.
I'm not kidding.
They send me all the time.
I,
I'm good.
I literally did marry a couple that one fear factor together.
Oh,
she carried them in Vegas with the nicer,
cool.
Divorced.
Yeah,
I hope so.
I ran into someone a long time ago.
Them just a little bit dry.
Just blow it on her homeboy Uber little.
Oh yeah.
Don't worry.
We're good.
Don't,
no one
calls to a
push.
Hey listen,
I'm trying to make something happen here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is my second person I've convinced into smoking weed this month.
Number one was Graham Hancock number.
Graham Hancock,
a friend of mine,
his name is BC is going on.
You have a friend named beasties.
His name's BC,
and he's going,
he's going on one of Graham Hancock's tours in Egypt.
Plan.
He's amazing.
I love the shit out of that guy.
And he was on the podcast and he had taken a three year break from marijuana and
he was talking about how he missed it while you realize it was kind of abusing
it and who's doing it all day.
And it was used again as a crutch.
And he did Iowasca and he recognized the fact that he was using it as a crutch.
And then on the podcast he was talking about how he missed it.
And so he took one,
maybe two heads,
and then just opened up like a flower.
Beautiful.
You snip is a reason why the table so flight is going to trust my instincts.
I love him so much.
But he started talking about,
he started talking and like with these great passion about these ancient
civilizations that probably existed in Egypt and the resistance to accepting
them and he has his office.
This is fucking beautiful wrap.
It's like a song.
Lee,
when he,
when we really locks into it,
when he really locks into this discussion of these ancient civilizations,
it's such a passion for him that he's constructed the narrative and like this
really beautiful melodic sort of like,
oh,
like a play.
So when he tells it to you,
it's hypnotic.
You know,
he's,
Tom's gone so deep.
So Dean,
that's incredible.
And every year some new shit comes out that makes him,
where's that coming from?
What do you mean?
Which which?
Which says new shit.
Is that archaeology or?
Yeah.
Well there's every year.
Like grandma,
if you don't know,
Graham Hancock rang.
Graham wrote an amazing book called the fingerprints of the gods and
fingerprints of the gods are footprints.
Fingerprints.
I think it's for me to make sure
the two feet in the beach and stuff.
Yeah.
Footprints of the God's fingerprints.
Fingerprints on the gun.
Okay.
Fingerprints.
Anyway,
sorry,
I forget.
I've read it and I forget.
It's just a title.
It's just a word.
Just noise you make with your mouth,
but the idea behind it was that what he believed is that there are established
areas of the world where there's archeology that they can't quite explain.
Massive stones cut with extreme precision,
moved into position.
John Hinges,
nothing.
There's a place called [inaudible] back in Lebanon,
something greater than Stonehenge.
Holy Shit,
dude.
It's not just one.
There's a bunch of them.
It's like the oldest pyramids have survived much longer than the newer pyramids.
There was a certain,
I don't know about all that that's in the book,
but the Pure,
the pyramid thing
is really under dispute between people that are real and Shit Egyptologists and
people like John Anthony West who's this brilliant alternative Egyptology
thinker and Graham Hancock and a lot of these revisionist guys.
There's still some debate as to what's correct and what's not correct,
but there's been a lot of evidence that that dates the great pyramid.
It's like the pyramid of Giza to 2,500 BC and that doesn't jive with this Guy
Robert Schoch who's a geologist at Boston University and this Guy John Anthony
West and Graham Hancock who believed that there's all sorts of evidence that
there was massive erosion that probably came from rainfall and one of them was
on the inside.
The enclosure with a Sphinx was built,
so we,
the Sphinx was built,
it was sort of cut out of this,
you know,
big stone quarry and the stones that were cut out where presumably smooth but
over like thousands and thousands of years have become like contoured.
And the debate is whether or not that contour is because of erosion with sand
and wind or because of water.
And there's a bunch of geologists that have got behind the water and they're
saying this is water erosion.
This is consistent with water erosion.
The number one being the most prominent.
Robert Schoch who is a geologist at Boston University,
he's done a bunch of papers on this and explained that what we're probably
looking at is thousands of years of rainfall.
That's a of these things which would predate the construction of this area.
The cutout,
the,
the like the,
the flat wall,
this area to like 9,000 BC,
which they don't have any civilizations that they knew of before,
like that age.
If it was me making that kind of shit,
but then they found some stuff in Turkey called Gold Beckley Tempe.
They found this big structure that's like this.
They're just in covering it now.
I think they've only got like 10% of it uncovered.
So every innocence,
14,000 years old between 12 and 14,000 years old.
So every year,
like they find more shit.
That makes Graham Hancock's theories like look more and more plausible.
And then he's got together with a bunch of other people that know about like
asteroidal impacts this guy Randall Carlson,
who's an,
he's an expert on extinction events like asteroidal impacts and
and events.
Besides the dinosaur thing.
What has been a fuck load of time?
Look,
keep deferring it this been a fuck load of that talk.
And they think they happen all the time,
man.
They think they have them like every 12 13,000 years.
So we'll,
okay,
so 12 13,000 years ago,
what went extinct as a result of an asteroid exploding?
I don't even know what I'm saying.
They believe like this is,
there's a lot of like guesswork when it comes to anything that's like 12,000
years ago.
There's a lot of like,
what the hell happened?
Who knows?
Like we like to think of 12,000 is like,
look,
if you have $12,000 you can't buy a house.
You know,
if you borrow a car,
if you buy a car for $12,000 don't expect to impress anybody,
right?
Right.
If you're,
you know,
$12,000 it's not much.
So 12,000 years,
Eh,
what is that?
It doesn't seem that much,
but it's
I'll fucking long time and 12,000 years ago,
it's very possible that Earth was smashed all over the place with these
asteroidal impacts.
They keep finding all this stuff like they found recently found these micro
diamonds that indicates some sort of impact and then they found this stuff
called nuclear glass.
It's like it's like called Triton night or something like that.
And it comes from impacts from these giant rocks just slamming into the earth
and it's all all over like Europe and Asia.
It's all hot around 12,000 years ago.
Does that speak to any extinction that happened or is that the kind of thing
where like,
okay,
these,
these headed in a different part of the world so it didn't affect the
environment like the dinosaur media or,
well,
I'm totally talking out of school.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I have no scholar lead degrees on any of the subject convincing.
But the way it's been explained to me is there's a great mystery involving what
happens when you have like,
uh,
w w.
W what happens when you have like some big extinction event?
Like where you like have no saber tooth tigers left.
You have no wooly tooth.
Mammas what happened?
How'd they all die and they've pinpointed a very specific time and it
corresponds the same time.
They're finding this stuff all over the place.
This stuff,
when they do the core samples,
so some,
it's very likely,
it's somewhere around 12,000 years ago we got fucked up.
Giant rocks from the sky just came down and fucked everything up and a few few
people made it,
you know,
who knows how many.
So the,
the humans were actually present then?
Most likely.
Yeah.
100% 12,000 years ago is gone that long.
Weird.
We probably looked exactly like us.
Oh totally.
Tattoos.
I don't mean like that,
but I mean like our structure,
like if you took a dude,
they probably didn't get as much food so they would probably like smaller.
But if you took a brain though,
very similar,
right?
If you could took a person,
you know,
regular person from 12,000 years ago and put them in a movie theater and walk by
them while you're sitting in your seat.
You have no idea it would look like to you.
I mean,
it was us,
Jesus.
So those people probably had to start all over.
But,
but depending on where this is,
what I'm just to understand is depending on where the APP asteroid
or make me smoke,
it's gonna go.
Great.
This is going to give bed.
I lost my sparkle.
What sparkle did you lose?
One
please continue what you were saying.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just going hit anything.
Why'd you lose your sparkle?
I don't know.
See,
this is what I'm saying.
I'm not a good weed smoker.
You're fine.
I think you're killing it.
I think you guys should talk and I should not put this on the Internet.
No,
I
think it will be awesome.
Maybe in a second.
Fingerprints and Gods by Graham Hancock Gentlemen.
Fingerprints of the gods that's available as Amazon taking too much.
No,
it's Amazon.
Super fucked up,
Joe.
No,
no.
If it did,
it would they have missiles and tags?
Definitely not super fucked up.
I think you're looking at it like a scale of fucked up.
Amazon's nowhere near like super fucked up.
They're super convenient.
Right?
Are they running shit and chasing people out of the fucking business and like,
oh no man crushing things.
Is that what they're doing?
I don't know.
You gotta be a general result.
amazon.com.
Yeah.
Oh man,
they make life so fucking convenience.
I put it.
Is that you're sacrificing anything else?
Cause I don't know.
I don't know.
Depends,
I mean like the,
the people that they're sort of,
um,
uh,
affecting or like the big business like target,
you know,
or,
or whatever.
Like you,
you can buy your toilet paper,
your dish soap,
your,
your laundry detergent on Amazon.
You're both show about two days.
What about the small Internet vendors?
You know,
it's like you're talking about all these other,
it's not that tailored.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't have like,
if you want.
So sometimes there's like intricate,
um,
I don't know,
fucking vitamin supplements or whatever.
But for the most part it's the,
are you okay?
Yo,
I'm good.
No,
no,
no.
I'd be massaging my fucking control.
But this is kind of the tip of Tony Nipples.
Whoa.
I don't know if,
I don't know if Amazon,
honey,
hi.
You don't know what's going to happen.
We're fine.
We're almost home.
We're amongst friends.
You've got Jesus Christ.
I don't know,
maybe it was too much of a question.
Wait,
can I go back to Amazon?
Fuck yeah,
I think Amazon is amazing.
So it kind of takes a little,
you know,
dig at the big business for,
for convenience purposes.
If you have prime,
you know,
you can get all the shit in two days,
but it's not,
it's not like you can get,
um,
like an intricate tailored item that you need for the most part.
Sure.
I guess that makes sense.
I don't necessarily think it cuts out business as much.
It's not comparable.
They're very efficient and it's convenient for people,
but they kind of have a monopoly on the,
like,
we're going to ship shit for you today.
Well,
do they have a monopoly?
I don't think they do.
I think a lot of people sell things on the Internet.
Here's what I was just really good at figuring out that you know you can make it
super convenient.
You one click.
I mean they're one of the few companies that started that.
Right.
Here's why I think it's the monopoly though.
And this is just for me.
Can you think of one other company that does the same thing?
You're on Amazon.
You sell your shit on them.
They just dropped the price.
Great service
I think
to them.
I love Amazon.
I get like if I get drunk at night,
like just kidding.
I will just order shoots to Amazon.
Sure.
What are you asking?
Do you have a question?
No,
I do.
I did.
I already asked it anyway.
Oh Man.
It's nothing wrong with it.
They're just the best at it.
They're great order.
They send your shit if you can't keep up.
Now there's Alibaba so that might change shit.
What's that?
Alibaba is like the Amazon.
How do I not know something that you know?
I've heard about Ali Baba
cause I was passing.
This is how much I think life is a simulation.
I was passing by this newspaper Rack and there's this dude and I was like,
Alibaba,
now worth more than Google.
Facebook.
They just publicly traded company in the world.
And I was walking by,
I was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Like what am I,
what is this?
Am I looking at what the fuck is Alibaba?
It's like an uh,
maybe not Townsend's side project.
Fuck,
what is Alibaba?
As far as I understand it,
it's a movie.
Do you know Alibaba?
It's like,
sorry,
that startup that made like,
it's like an Asian equivalent of Amazon,
you know,
they facilitate businesses trading with consumer anyway.
It is.
So it's like a Amazon for China.
What you do is you,
it's like you're hiring companies to do things for you.
So like if you want like a thousand like wallets with your face on it,
you can con con
it's a manufacturer.
No,
no,
they,
they just the second directory of manufacturers or like a distribution network.
Yeah.
And it's basically,
it's similar to Amazon,
but it's just gotten so big and because China's such a huge market,
it just went global and it's at least at the time that it was going out,
the biggest globally traded co,
it was going to be on the precipice of that.
Wow.
When you think about the numbers of people to go with it,
the Asian market is like,
think about how many people were in China.
It's like a billion plus,
right?
1.6 billion.
Something like God is,
it's that high.
Is that real?
Would probably more than probably more than that.
So like close to a million,
like say to hunt,
like one point a billion,
2 million,
a thousand million plus another 600 million.
She say,
sorry,
sorry.
600,000 men to book more than what we are.
Yeah.
That's insane.
We're a 350 million.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Just think about how many goddamn people
know what's bad.
You're fine,
Jamie.
I love being a dick.
No,
she's fine.
Both everybody's good.
Just think about the numbers.
Think about how many Chinese folks are,
are,
and then add that to Asian folks.
That's another billion.
Yeah,
sure.
Thanks.
Think about that.
Asian folks,
Asian folks like China,
India,
India is another billion.
Right close to it.
Yeah,
Dude.
Japan,
Indonesia.
It's amazing though.
It's really,
man.
It's exciting.
Have you been,
when was the last time you were in Japan?
We are a swarm.
We're a
swarm on this planet.
You don't swarm.
There's,
there's billions of us.
You were like this when you did it.
I was trying to be like wonder woman.
I'll try and real was,
I was thinking strong.
Linda Carter.
We're a swarm with us a lot,
so as the low hanging fruit,
I mean that was obvious.
There was a fucking lot of us people,
you know,
I mean there's still plenty of space.
Don't get is why some of us,
that's good.
The good friends she band together
called cult are ready.
It starts out,
you call a common and your chickens and your hunting excursion.
The police call it a cult.
Chickens.
This is no this chicken conversation.
Chickens are great.
I think that would be like one of the best things you could do other than plant
vegetables.
Plant vegetables.
Equally satisfying.
It's a beautiful vegetable.
Yeah,
it's cool to be able to pick vegetables out of the ground.
I mean,
I don't do enough of it.
I would like to do all of my vegetables,
like planted garden vegetables.
I just think that'd be like the coolest thing to be,
have like a complete direct relationship with all the food you eat.
You know?
That would be amazing.
What,
what are the missing?
That right.
We'll give you eat a chicken or you like thank you.
Don't have that kind of relationship with chicken.
I don't pretend the dietary needs.
No,
I just go lizard.
You eat lizards?
No,
I just go lizard,
lizard,
part of the brain shrimping.
Just mentally.
No.
If you're going to kill a chicken,
you just,
you go lizard,
you know?
Can't have a lot of compassion.
So yeah.
Honestly,
as far as like the spirit animal connections go,
chickens don't feel connected to them.
Cows,
pigs,
goats.
It's a different thing with mammals.
You know,
chickens are weird.
They're dinosaurs are a strange bird.
That probably doesn't
make sense.
You don't fucking fly.
We're keeping them around where the reason they're around.
Yeah.
Why are you putting the picture?
Look,
you're looking at the time.
Why are you doing that?
So if you wanted it to play anymore,
uh,
another song,
another song.
Brian,
we're talking about chickens.
Yeah,
we're just having fun and their souls
happens after we laid it,
but joint chickens and cows and goats,
there's set.
There's so many differences and their spiritual connectivity.
You got it.
You painted the picture.
Dared me to smoke the gunge.
Susie,
this is bad,
isn't it?
No,
it's no,
it's fine.
We're talking about virtual farms.
Every question.
Ben,
please put your hand up.
You guys are in class today.
Thank you for [inaudible] your hair.
This is like Lord of the flies in here.
Dude.
Someone's got to pass the ball.
I mean Florida fives
violence is sorry.
Eventually it is about,
that's that story.
We were making our own dark,
getting darker flies.
It's still my question.
I'm sorry Lord of the rings reference.
I would have been more excited.
You had to go with flies.
Sorry.
Okay.
I see vegetables.
What?
You're growing new garden.
Is it native to here?
Ooh,
good question.
Very good question.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
Why?
Like what?
Okay.
Like what is,
if you're going to grow lettuce,
lettuce,
speak.
What's lettuce like?
Regular Romaine lettuce.
What's that native sue.
I have no idea.
It's America.
Romania.
We grow in in Ohio.
Right,
but I mean it's just a regular North American plants.
I don't think that you don't have the weather doesn't have to be,
you know,
it could just be,
you just need to have sunlight guys.
We got Google.
There's some
props that need more sunlight.
[inaudible]
standing there like this guys.
We got guys,
we got
to that brand.
That's a meme,
bro.
Fuck,
fuck your meme.
The fuck on here.
Some.
It's very important you get me because they're saying that it's not going to
happen.
That's how it works.
That's not how it works.
I don't know how it works.
There's no,
no one knows how it works.
We don't know it.
It worked better.
My skin tone.
I think we should play the song.
You know which one do you want it?
Well Joe,
please do you want us to play song?
What do you guys want to play?
We were trying to figure that out or like non ballad.
I want whatever you guys want to play.
Okay.
Fuck it.
He fucked you want a paper?
Rock.
Scissors.
And for what?
What's the choices?
I'll be valid.
And you be,
um,
what else to know?
What are the salt?
Oh,
burned me out and bad people.
I think we should do burn,
ma'am.
I think it's a beautiful song and I,
okay.
Is it possible to make a request for anytime in the future?
Yes sir.
Could you do,
let's get wrecked.
Oh Shit.
Did double.
Can we put that on ice for a second for a second?
Because we don't have the necessary instruments.
We could do like an acoustic version.
That's all I'm talking about.
I'm not asking you to bring in a band.
I think we could do.
Cool.
Alright.
I'm not playing guitar though.
No,
no,
I'll do it.
I have no idea what you guys are arguing over.
That's what I love about being musically.
Don't listen.
If you guys are more comfortable doing something else,
please do.
Don't listen to me.
Let's do burn me out.
Well now have to do that.
No,
no,
don't.
I don't want to put you on the spot.
That's not fair.
I don't understand.
I'm happy already so we could stop this shit right now.
This shit before it gets ugly.
We'll all be happy.
Okay,
so fuck you.
I just play whatever you want,
please.
Whatever you guys want to walk.
Go ahead.
Any song that's in your head right now.
Ben,
what's in your head?
What's in your head do we have for now?
Bring me out.
Don't worry about this fucking stupid clock.
You can see your ankles.
What they look like.
Ride that bit heartbreaking.
Right into the rocks.
No,
it is.
It's beautiful.
We're gonna ride this boat into the rocks kids.
This is called burned me out.
Wjr night.
Seven 10 Pacific by the boner.
Honey.
Yeah,
you're a girl.
What the fuck,
Joe?
Just go with it.
Suzanne.
Let's check that out.
Amplifier.
Excellent
nonsense.
Bull Shit.
And opportunity to say that we're going on tour and we really,
really want to see you guys.
Whoever is listening,
if you're in the cities on our website,
yes,
they're posted on our website.
And what's that website?
Suzann honey,
honey,
honey band in Texas and Colorado,
New Mexico,
California.
honey.com in the state of your mom's house.
The youtube video might just so the audio listeners,
they'll beat you.
Yeah.
You stream if you give out on me.
I understand you weak ass bitch can only do three hours have,
we've been doing a podcast for three hours.
Jesus,
Mary and Joseph.
We Ustream is strong.
They're going to hang in there.
I feel this.
This is a new ballot.
Fill this.
Um,
hopefully it'll be,
it'll be on a record.
If not,
you'll,
you'll have it here forever here.
Testing.
Okay.
It's called burn me out.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Oh,
ah,
Yo.
Words.
I books.
Hanni hook lacks summertime cooking.
I'm a mom and all the way through.
Okay.
I guess I held on to,
I broke my fingers on you.
Oh,
I lost my faith.
Ooh.
I love can feel like this
is
ah,
really?
Oh Bam.
Oh Man.
Oh
say that God knows away
but I'm standing and
I soaked up.
You Rung me.
Oh
No.
Ah.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
Oh Man.
They burn me.
Don't feel good.
Ah,
oh
you,
I am well cause us trouble
back on you at
oh
no.
Hm.
Ah Okay.
Cause
yeah,
ages.
Yeah.
Was Fun.
That was fucking cool.
You guys are awesome.
You're awesome Joe.
It's so cool to be friends with you guys.
I'm so God damn impressed.
I just love when I see someone like when I see
like a band that like taps into this weird like very consistent kind of special
energy that comes from like songs that just flow your songs.
Like your songs are so like representative of you guys.
You know.
It's weird.
Been now knowing you guys as friends and then like seeing your writing and
seeing the music and the singing together and seeing like the new songs being
created.
It's really fascinating.
It's so weird.
I have no skill ms musically or talent or knowledge or nothing.
So when I see the truth it,
that's 100% true.
No,
I'm telling you.
So when I see like someone who can sing and people can put music together and
fascinating shit man.
That was awesome.
Thanks man.
Thanks for having us.
Anytime.
Anytime you guys,
the Shit,
this is this day only band I've ever worked with.
Whatever,
we'd never worked with anybody else.
Well,
ever last oh button,
but never on the road.
All right.
Never first show.
We've talked about doing that.
That would be the shit you guys Everlast Joey Diaz
like it's a lot like comedy that I stand up at least though.
I Dunno.
I've never done standup,
but I just feel like performing it.
It's kind of the same energy or,
or I,
yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I think it's all like whatever the fuck you're trying to get out a you through
whatever medium,
whether it's playing the violin or,
or doing stand up.
Yeah.
It's all,
what's,
what's trying to get out of you,
whether it's,
you know,
building a house,
whether it's fucking putting a car together,
you know,
like when people do things that they're trying to express,
like something about their own curiosity and creativity is trying to put
something together.
It's like it show it to other people and go,
look,
whether it's,
you know,
creating a book or creating an idea that turns into a song that turns into it
hit,
it turns.
It's like we're trying to get something to where they could look at that.
Look how good I found it.
I found this and the other dimension,
dimension of creativity.
I brought it back.
Look,
look,
oh you have to do is you sit down by yourself and you tune in.
He just got to tune in and you write everything down and you figure it out and
then you practice it and look,
look,
look what I got now.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what you're doing.
That's what anybody who is creating anything,
whether they're creating a movie there,
they're figuring out how to like
go deep in the imagination and like pull something out of their fucking head and
hold it up for you.
Yeah,
and what and what's [inaudible] last words?
I'm with you my friend.
I'm like,
you too,
but I don't know why.
Unity.
Stay together.
Stay alert.
Stay alive.
Susan.
What'd you call me?
I said stay alert.
Stay alive.
You call me Susan Suzanne all the way and we don't have to Emma.
I don't want to.
That's my new tattoo.
Susie had all the way
trend.
That should be trend cross country Hashtag.
If you're thinking about doing that.
I'm fucking kidding.
Don't get that Tattoo.
Jeez.
You and I are going to spend some time together.
That's,
that's pretty
big
words.
Just kidding.
Giant gap was too,
too big.
It's too great.
That was should we should fine.
Particularly rural friends.
I'm just going to keep forging ahead with this.
I don't know what
this is.
The Internet,
what she just said about,
you know,
the well of creativity.
The exciting point to me about that is it's all the same thing.
It's the same.
Well and the only difference then is just some sort of technical aspect.
Did you learn
to do stand up?
Did you learn to play the guitar?
Did you learn to make movies?
It,
it doesn't make a difference,
you know,
at that.
That's just like what the path of your creativity flows through for the rest of
your painting or whether it's your music or whether it's your,
whatever it is,
the path,
the path of your creativity,
whatever it flows through.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's like a raw technical element and that's it.
So what really matters is where you're coming from from that well perspective.
You know,
maybe,
but I mean that's the other thing is that like,
I feel like certain people are just drawn to certain certain type of activities,
certain disciplines,
certain things.
And when they resist that,
there's like huge issues with humans crease.
But I totally,
that's exactly what we were talking about earlier.
And it's like a huge loss of confidence for people suppression.
Well,
you just,
you feel bad.
You feel like it's almost like there's a just grand puzzle going on and you,
you know,
you just kinda like going towards which,
what's pulling you and is it healthy that it's pulling you in this direction?
Like examine it,
figure it out,
figure out what it is,
and if you could resist it because you're,
well,
it's not a sure thing or it's not,
how do you feel about that
conformity then in that respect?
Like,
like you being Joe,
you know,
and then you're in certain social settings or whatever.
Do you,
um,
you know,
are you malleable?
Can you change into a way that like,
you're like,
oh yeah,
I'm with this crowd,
or
Oh,
I can talk,
I can talk to anybody.
I mean,
yeah,
I sit in a room full of born again Christians and have a friendly conversation
with them.
I probably couldn't have a decade ago.
Yeah.
But somewhere along the line I've realized it doesn't matter if you're right or
I'm right.
Uh,
it's not a fucking game.
Okay.
And so instead of quantifying it as a game,
which is like a thing that guys love to do,
we love to do it.
We want to be right.
People love to do.
People love to do it.
But guys specifically because guys likes me feel better,
guys like the fucking win arguments,
you know,
it's a barbarian thing.
It's some fucking weird,
you know,
pubs,
sword fight,
shit leftover from the fucking dark ages.
I don't know.
So sorry.
You know,
I don't know if it's a gender specific thing.
I think sometimes you just want to connect with people.
It's not so much about dudes and,
or ladies,
you know,
I think I used to feel really guilty about being able to conform so easily
because I love everybody.
Cause I,
I would,
I can,
I can hang out all the time.
And then,
and then I was like,
well why did I just like exploit myself?
Right?
Exploit parts of myself to fit in here,
you know what I mean?
But at the same time,
I think it's okay to just be,
um,
have accessible aspects of yourself to connect with people.
Yeah.
I mean,
absolutely.
are you going to occasionally run it?
That's
like a male.
I think that's across the board.
Yeah.
No,
that's across the board.
I agree
with what you just said it.
I think,
I dunno the being argumentative or like,
I mean women driving towards conflict,
man are women are we all are,
right?
It's just,
it's not really gender dependent.
Yeah,
but I think there's a extra like sort of dominated or trait that a lot of men
tend to have,
you know,
that want them to win arguments,
especially when this podcast,
how do you,
when it is this kind of game planning,
like the dominant one guys will all that.
I feel like we're all winning his pocket.
I like the way you talk.
You're like a fucking politician.
Oh my God.
I got a new name for you.
This is what you just did it.
So Jesus,
Jesus,
in case for cheesy savior,
you're Jesus.
Pray for cheeses.
Do you know who tells us that joke in case of Ben's mother,
Jesus.
She told you that Jesus chose,
she told me.
I swear to God.
I thought I was making that up.
No,
Ben,
you guys heard that before?
Is there a cheeses choke the cheesy Jesus Ben Ben's mom from Wisconsin cheese.
Oh,
in Kaiso emergency in case of emergency.
Pray for cheese.
Oh boy.
I'm sorry.
But that is an acceptable racial,
not racist.
I don't feel like there was any anger involved.
I feel like it was all done in the spirit of love and the reality of the way
some mother fuckers talk and out.
It's not bad the way they speak.
English is better than the way I would speak Spanish.
Okay.
And my mom's heart Ecuadorian.
Amazing.
We're even safer.
We're even safer now.
Joe,
is that,
what was it making you said that Joe on this podcast and I knew it knew it
would.
How dare you?
No,
it wasn't doubting.
I was just like,
wow,
this is the least musical and most silly of all the podcasts
on them.
What did we do this so horrible.
We had some fun.
What did we do?
We had a few good friends,
had a bunch of laughs together.
What did we do?
Air Raid.
I heard,
apparently I googled it.
There was a jet that invaded the airspace.
No Shit.
I don't know.
Sure.
Planes.
Sort of a plane.
That was 2013
Obama's entire incorrect.
I just googled it and looked at the first one.
I didn't even look at the date it was trying to
smoldering 2013 that's what happened.
Do you want to find
out about the 2000 event,
which
I was accidentally referencing.
How about this?
Cause the ball keeps rolling.
Hey Ho Ho.
Hey you gotta you gotta keep rolling.
If you don't snooze,
you lose.
That's Brian Dj Red Bank.
Sorry.
Sore though.
Honey.
band.com
is that where they should go,
honey?
Honey,
honey.
honey.com Twitter,
Facebook,
or is the porn site?
Oh my God.
I would call it.
Is it a beekeeper fetish?
Rudimentary level kid grabbing like chokes there.
We're using the fucking beekeepers out.
Choke each other was autoerotic IX fixation due to d chokes on beekeepers up
fits,
peaks,
hurt,
good collar choke beekeeper
podcasts.
We can end this right now.
Honey,
honey band on Twitter.
honey band on Instagram.
And of course Facebook and you guys this shit.
This was fun.
I enjoyed this.
This was a lot of fun.
You guys are always as always awesome.
Brian Redman,
ladies and gentlemen.
[inaudible] dot.
TV.
Go there by some tee shirts.
Support,
support the death squad empire.
And uh,
that's it.
You fucks.
Oh,
uh,
next weekend I will be in Philadelphia and I will be in Washington DC,
Philadelphia on the 17th.
I'll be at the tower theater and then the Warner Theater in Washington DC.
Dirty,
dirty freaks.
So,
uh,
I'll see you guys soon and a lot more podcasts this week.
Ladies and gentleman,
Keith Weber,
Anthony Komi up going to get crazy,
so we'll see you soon.
Much love big kiss.
Yeah.